Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast der Metaebene mit Unterstützung des Zeiss Großplanetariums in Berlin. Und mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur Ausgabe 65 bei unseren Flügen durch Raum und Zeit. Und dieses Projekt ist ja mal gestartet worden mit der Unterstützung von ESA und DLR. Mittlerweile führe ich das ja alleine fort und oft ist halt in den ersten Jahren hier diese ESA-Seite, die organisierte Raumfahrt thematisiert worden. Und heute möchten wir mal einen Blick werfen auf die anderen Projekte, die es nämlich mittlerweile auch gibt. Die versuchen hier ihren eigenen Weg zu gehen und ganz konkret geht es heute um die Part-Time-Scientists und ihren Weg zum Mond. Und dazu begrüße ich erst mal Carsten, nämlich Carsten Becker. Carsten, du bist ein Teilzeit-Wissenschaftler sozusagen.
Ja, also ich sage mal so, als wir angefangen haben, war das mit Sicherheit richtig. Also da haben wir es wirklich in unserer Freizeit gemacht. Mittlerweile haben wir dann aber doch Angestellte. Das heißt, ich bin auch einer der ersten Angestellten, die wir quasi haben. Also unsere Idee ist ernst geworden sozusagen. Richtig, genau. Also es ist so, dass Ende 2008 hat der Robert Böhme eine Mail bekommen, wo es hieß, es gibt da diesen komischen Wettbewerb, den Google Lunar X Prize, wo es darum geht, ein Fahrzeug zum Mond zu bringen, mit dem 500 Meter zurückzulegen und währenddessen HD-Videos zu Erde zu übertragen. Und er hatte sich gewundert, ob das irgendwie möglich ist. Also vor allem der Schwerpunkt ist, dass man das privat finanziert macht, also nicht über staatliche Gelder. Und er hat dann ein paar seiner Freunde mal befragt und aus irgendwelchen Gründen haben die befunden, dass das wohl möglich sein muss. Und so hat sich dann das Kernteam von den Part-Time-Scientists gefunden, die alle halt aus unterschiedlichen Bereichen kommen. Also da hatte jeder seinen eigenen Job und hat dann einfach in der Freizeit an dieser Mission gearbeitet. Und Ende 2009, auf dem 26.3, haben die Part-Time-Scientists das Projekt dann vorgestellt, der Öffentlichkeit zum ersten Mal.
Also dem 26. Chaos Communication Congress des Chaos-Kunst-Doktors.
Genau, richtig. Und dann habe ich davon auch gehört und habe mir gedacht, das ist so verrückt, da muss ich auf jeden Fall mitmachen. Und seit 2010 bin ich jetzt quasi dabei. Und seit April letzten Jahres bin ich auch dann Vollzeit angestellt. Also wir haben zwischendrin ein paar Erfolge gehabt. Es war so, dass dieser Wettbewerb, der Google Lunar X Prize, der wurde 2007 ins Leben gerufen. Und der war halt wirklich sehr lange Zeit, irgendwie Wanderteams am rumschwabern, aber haben wir nicht geschafft. Und deshalb hat Google dann gesagt, okay, pass auf, jetzt machen wir so einen Zwischenwettbewerb, wo sich die Teams bewerben können. Und die müssen dann zeigen, dass ihre Hardware, die sie entwickelt haben, für den Einsatz auf dem Mond tatsächlich geeignet ist. Und an diesem Zwischenwettbewerb haben wir dann 750.000 Dollar gewonnen und haben damit dann unser Berliner Büro aufgemacht, im Malstorf im April letzten Jahres war das dann. Und dann haben wir noch zusätzlich Audi als Unterstützung dazu gewonnen. Und seitdem arbeiten wir halt wirklich Vollzeit, Volldampf an dieser Mission, um das hinzubekommen.
Okay, also das ist sozusagen alles ernst. Das ist nicht nur so ein Witz mit Haha, schick mal was auf den Mond, sondern hier geht es um the real thing. Bevor wir vielleicht noch mehr und im Detail auf das Projekt eingehen, würde mich natürlich noch mal interessieren, wie du eigentlich sozusagen hier in die Spur gekommen bist. Du bist ja auch eine vergleichsweise junge Generation noch und das heißt, du wirst nicht von der Mondlandung initial infiziert worden sein. Gab es irgendwas Vergleichbares oder ist das eher Zufall, dass du so in diesem Bereich abgekneten bist?
Also ich habe mich schon immer für ferngestellte Autos begeistert, sag ich jetzt mal, und bin dann mit meinem Vater auch einmal in den Wald gegangen, bin dann mit ihm rumgefahren und dann ist es aber irgendwie immer auseinandergefallen. Und dann hat die NASA ja den ersten Marsrover hochgesendet und das hat mich wirklich so wahnsinnig beeindruckt, dass ich sage, okay Raumfahrt ist geil, da möchte ich auch mitmachen. Also das war der erste Marsrover? Passfarnamission 1996. Und da habe ich dann...
Richtig, 1996.
Und da habe ich dann, das war für mich mein persönliches Apollo, wo ich dachte so, okay Raumfahrt ist geil, das möchte ich irgendwie auch mitmachen. Und habe dann halt mein Studium durchgezogen, Technische Informatik, also gar nicht mal irgendwie so Raumfahrt-mäßig. Und als ich mal mein Master fertig war, habe ich mir überlegt, okay, was mache ich jetzt? Gehe ich jetzt irgendwie in die Raumfahrt? Hab mir dann so die Stellenanzeigen durchgelesen, habe dann gedacht, okay, DLR, irgendwas, Crown Support, irgendwas, Gedöns. Klingt irgendwie total langweilig nach Bürokratie und irgendwas. Dann habe ich gedacht, okay, das lässt du erstmal. Und habe eine Doktorstelle in der TU Hamburg angetreten. Und dann aber auch gleichzeitig von dem Part-Time-Scientist gehört und mich dann auch gleichzeitig da angemeldet quasi.
Was hast du genau studiert?
Technische Informatik.
Okay, also eine reine normale Informatik.
Richtig, genau.
Und hast du auch zu Ende gemacht. Also kannst du kein abgebrochenes Informatikstudium vorweisen.
Nee, nee, das habe ich tatsächlich zu Ende gemacht. Aber bei meiner Doktorarbeit, da muss ich nur noch zusammen schreiben. Dann habe ich dann irgendwann mal meinen Doktor.
Wenn du mal Zeit findest.
Das ist das Problem, genau.
Part-Time-Diplom-Arbeit sozusagen.
Ja, also ich hoffe ja eher darauf, dass ich dann einen Ehrendoktor bekomme, wenn wir die Mission durchgezogen haben. Das ist, glaube ich, wahrscheinlich eher, als dass ich schaffe, meine Arbeit zu Ende zu schreiben.
Okay, jetzt ist natürlich auch, gut, kann man so oder so sehen, technische Informatik ist ja jetzt nicht per se ein Studiengang, der einen unmittelbar zur Raumfahrt bringt. Auch wenn es natürlich offensichtlich ist, dass es da Bedarf gibt für Informatik, keine Frage. Hast du irgendwie den Eindruck gehabt, dass sich das Studium schon auch, sagen wir mal, richtig ausgerüstet hat, mit einem Basiswerkzeug, um dort bestehen zu können, oder ist es eher trotzdem zu kommen?
Also, was ich ganz interessant finde an unserem Team ist halt, dass die Leute eigentlich alle nicht aus der Raumfahrt kommen. Also, wenn man sich anguckt, also Robert Böhme ist IT-Security-Consultant für den Bund, also der Gründer quasi, und wir haben dann zum Beispiel auch einen Baumarkt-Mitarbeiter, und das ist man die Gründer des Teams. Also, die kommen alle aus dem Nicht-Space-Bereich, und wir haben einfach gesagt, dass das muss irgendwie gehen, und haben uns dann das Wissen selber erarbeitet, was man braucht. Und das hat halt auch wirklich ein paar Jahre gedauert, aber mittlerweile kann man eigentlich auch nicht mehr behaupten, dass ich nicht aus der Raumfahrt komme. Also, wenn man irgendwie seit sechs Jahren irgendwie, oder jetzt fast sieben, daran arbeitet, dann gehen einem die Ausreden aus. Also, ja, also das ist halt, Technik und Informatik hat dahingehend geholfen, dass halt zum Beispiel viele FPGAs bei Raumfahrtprojekten benutzt werden. Und ich halt mich in meiner Doktorarbeit auch ein bisschen auf diese FPGA-Programmierung spezialisiert habe. Also, das hat dahingehend geholfen. Aber ansonsten, also der erste Rover wurde von einem Dentaltechniker entworfen. Und Alina wird von einem Philosophiestudenten, Germanistik-Mitarbeiter gemacht.
Ja, ich meine, am Ende zählt ja mehr auch die Passion und die Fähigkeit, die richtigen Lösungen zu finden für die Fragen, die anstehen. Alina, das gleichzueilige Lehrteil ist euer Landemodul. Da kommen wir auf jeden Fall noch dazu.
Also, was wir halt über die letzten Jahre wirklich gelernt haben, ist, dass wir, dass die anderen Institute, diese ESA und DLR und keine Ahnung, dass die eigentlich auch nur mit Wasser kochen. Also, wir haben immer, als wir angefangen haben, haben wir so eine wahnsinnige Ehrfurcht gehabt vor diesen Instituten und dachten, oh mein Gott, das sind dann diese Männer in diesen weißen Kitteln, die da über Raumfahrt alles Bescheid wissen. Und dann haben wir die nach und nach alle besucht. Und auch mit dem DLR haben wir ja schon seit mehreren Jahren eine Kooperation und haben festgestellt, okay, die arbeiten eigentlich genauso, wie wir das auch machen würden. Und von daher haben wir dann auch ein bisschen, ja, wir haben uns einfach mehr zugetraut, weil wir gelernt haben, dass das Raumfahrt eigentlich keine Rocket Science ist. Okay, es ist Rocket Science teilweise. Aber es ist einfacher, als wir gedacht haben.
Okay, ich weiß, was du meinst. Und meine Erfahrung war auch, was du sicherlich nicht sagen wolltest und ich auch nochmal betonen will, ist, selbstverständlich sind das alles Leute mit einer extremen Expertise, aber die primäre Auszeichnung, die man dort vorfindet, ist, dass die einfach in der Lage sind, immer Lösungen zu finden, in dem Moment, wo sich die Fragen stellen. Jede Mission ist heutzutage im Prinzip ein Prototyp und nichts ist im Wesentlichen zweimal gemacht worden. Natürlich verlässt man sich auf viel etablierte Technik, da wo sie einmal bewiesen hat, das funktioniert und es tut auch immer noch genau das, was man braucht. Und man muss eigentlich nur an den anderen Stellen arbeiten, wo das Neue entsteht. Aber es geht da hier vielmehr um Kreativität und es geht vielmehr um seinen Grips eigentlich in die richtige Richtung zu bewegen. Anstatt dass man jetzt davon ausgeht, wie bei so einem Handwerk, naja, man lernt das mal. Und dann macht man das 30 Jahre lang. Weil Raumfahrt heute und Raumfahrt vor 30 Jahren, will ich sagen, dass es nichts miteinander zu tun hat. Aber die Anforderungen ändern sich ja permanent. Mit der technischen Entwicklung, mit der Neudefinition von Missionen. Ja, oder eben auch mit der Änderung der Rahmenbedingungen, wie bei euch, dass einfach auch das ganze Finanzierungsmodell sozusagen auch nochmal anders aufgestellt ist.
Ja, man muss auch dazu sagen, dass halt wirklich die technische Entwicklung eines der Dinge ist, die uns das ermöglichen zu tun, was wir gerade tun. Also wenn man sich jetzt mal die Entwicklung im CubeSat-Bereich anschaut, also diesen Kleinstsatelliten-Bereichen, da werden mittlerweile ziemliche Standardprozessoren benutzt, also die quasi Arduino, sag ich jetzt mal. Und die sind halt mittlerweile strahlenfester und auch gut für die, also nicht gut, aber sind halt für bestimmte Missionstypen auch für die Raumfahrt geeignet. Und das ist zum Beispiel so eine technische Entwicklung, die uns eigentlich erst ermöglicht, Alina, also unsere gesamte Mission eigentlich überhaupt erst zu ermöglichen. Also wenn wir diese Jahrzehnten alte Produkte benutzen müssten, auf die jetzt die Standardraumfahrt zurückgreift, weil die sind ja schon mal geflogen, dann wären unsere Kosten in einem ganz anderen Rahmen und unsere technische Entwicklung wäre auch bei weitem nicht so weit fortgeschritten. Also dadurch, dass wir, wenn man sich überlegt, also die Rechenpower verdoppelt sich immer jedes Jahr. Und wenn man sich dann mal anschaut, was für einen Rechner auf Curiosity mitfliegt, der wurde vor 10 Jahren ausgewählt. Und seitdem ist er dann Standard geblieben. Und in 10 Jahren hat sich in der Rechenpower wirklich so viel getan. Das ist einfach enorm. Und wenn man da nicht auf diese Technologie zugreifen kann, dann wird es schwierig. Und unsere Mission ist ja zum Glück sehr kompakt. Also unsere Missionsdauer ist effektiv 1,5 Monate. Das heißt, wir fliegen mit der Rakete in die Umlaufbahn. Im Idealfall fliegen wir dann innerhalb von 5 Tagen rüber zum Mond. Wenn wir dann direkt landen können, dann sind wir auf der Mondüberfläche. Dort haben wir dann 11,5 Tage Operations, also wo wir dann im Rover wirklich herumfahren können. Und dann ist unsere Mission effektiv tot. Das heißt, im Best-Case ist es innerhalb von einem halben Monat quasi unsere Mission durch. Und da kann man natürlich auch andere Risiken eingehen, als wenn man jetzt einen geostationären Satelliten hochschicken müsste, der irgendwie 20 Jahre da funktionieren muss und vor allem Geld generieren muss. Das heißt, in unserer Mission setzen wir Technologie ein, die wirklich eher dem guten Industriestandard entspricht, als das, was in der Raumfahrtechnik seit Jahrzehnten eingesetzt wird.
Ich sage nur Vorsicht. Ich glaube Spirit und Opportunity wurden auch nur sechs Wochen Betriebszeit unterstellt und sind jetzt irgendwie seit zehn Jahren unterwegs.
Ja, also auf dem Mond gibt es eine ganz besondere Herausforderung. Also wir landen ja in der Nähe von Apollo 17 und das ist im Equator. Das heißt, die Bodentemperatur geht auf 120 Grad Celsius hoch zum Mittag. Und wenn dann die Nacht kommt, geht die Temperatur runter auf minus 180 Grad Celsius. Und das ist natürlich ziemlich hart. Du kannst ein Mondfahrzeug so designen, dass es diese hohen Temperaturen gut überlebt. Aber dann ist es genau das Falsche für diese niedrigen Temperaturen. Und wir haben ja keine radioaktiven Elemente an Bord, mit denen wir das Ding aufheizen könnten, über die Mondnacht hinüber. Also die Mondnacht ist ja immer ein halber Monat. Und das ist halt einfach viel zu lang, um mit Batterien irgendwas durchzuheizen. Und von daher, das sage ich jetzt als Ateist, wir werden beten und gucken. Vielleicht wacht er am nächsten Montag dann nochmal wieder auf. Wir gehen aber davon nicht aus der Zeit.
Noch mal kurz zu den Kooperationen jetzt mit dem DLR. Ich weiß nicht, gibt es auch eine Zusammenarbeit mit der ESA?
Also es ist so, dass wir auf ESA-Hardware zurückgreifen werden. Also S-Tech genauer gesagt. Das Testing Center. Genau, das Tracking Netzwerk. Und da sind wir mit denen gerade am verhandeln, wie wir das nutzen können. Das interessante an der ESA ist halt, wie sie sich innerhalb der letzten paar Jahre gewandelt hat. Als der Google Lunar X Prize ausgerufen wurde, gab es eine offizielle Pressemitteilung der ESA, wo drinne stand, dass sie diesen GLXP ganz furchtbar finden und auf gar keinen Fall unterstützen werden. Das hat sich jetzt wirklich drastisch geändert. Wenn man jetzt die Ministerratskonferenz anschaut, was da beschlossen wurde, sie nennt es Space 4.0, das ist quasi die Kommerzialisierung der Raumfahrt und das ist effektiv genau das, was wir machen. Da hat sich in den letzten paar Jahren wahnsinnig viel verändert.
Ich denke, es ist ja auch ein ähnlicher Trend, wie man das bei der NASA auch sieht, auch wenn jetzt gerade in diesen Zeiten ein bisschen unklar ist, wie es da weitergeht in den USA. Aber der Verzicht, eigene Staats durchzuführen, also die Raketenmissionen durchzuführen, denke ich war insofern auch sehr belebend, als dass man dadurch eben sehr aktiv so eine neue privat finanzierte Szene darauf beschworen hat, was ja auch ganz gut aussieht. Also mit SpaceX und anderen Firmen kommen jetzt ja einige Player, die auch in der Lage sind, ganz neue Ideen zu pitchen und ganz neue Ansätze zu verfolgen. Wie erfolgreich die jetzt mittelfristig sein werden, wird man sehen. Bisher ist es ja so schlecht nicht gelaufen. Und ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass sich im Rest der Welt und natürlich auch in Europa ein ähnlicher Effekt einstellen wird, ohne dass jetzt die NASA und damit natürlich auch die ESA ihre eigentliche Bedeutung verliert. Sondern man konzentriert sich halt auf das, was man am besten kann. Ich meine, Satelliten werden ja auch nicht von der ESA gebaut. Die werden ja auch schon von der Privatwirtschaft gebaut, die sich darauf eben spezialisieren. Weil das ist nicht die eigentliche Aufgabe der ESA und auch nicht die Aufgabe der NASA, sondern hier geht es darum, Wissenschaft und die Erfahrung des Missionsbetriebs mit einzubringen. Und wenn das dann sozusagen dritten Projekten helfen kann, dann ist das ja für beide Seiten gut, oder?
Genau, das denke ich auch. Ich denke, dass die Agenturen mehr in die Rolle kommen, dass sie sich um den wissenschaftlichen Anspruch der Mission kümmern und einen Teil der Verantwortung der Durchführung an kommerzielle Dienstleister abgeben. Einfach weil sich mit der Technologie so viel verändert hat, dass kommerzielle Dienstleister das einfach wesentlich kostengünstiger können, als wenn jetzt eine Agentur das machen muss, was einfach an der Natur der Funktionsweise dieser Agenturen liegt. Also wenn man halt erstmal eine Dokumentation schreiben muss, damit man die Ausschreibung machen kann, dann muss man Ausschreibung machen, dann muss man das evaluieren, dann müssen die Partner das entwickeln, dann müssen die die Dokumentation schreiben, um das dann wieder an die Agentur zurückzugeben. Da ist halt viel Reibungsverlust dazwischen. Und wenn du dann noch bei ESA zum Beispiel diesen Georetör beobachten musst, dann ist das natürlich noch noch ein bisschen schwieriger, sag ich mal. Also das war, das war glaube ich 2010. Da haben wir das erste Mal einen Stand auf der ILA gehabt und haben dort unsere zweite Generation von dem Rover vorgestellt. Und dann hat Armin Wettler vom DLR Oberpfaffenhofen das gesehen und hat gesagt, wahnsinn, die basteln da an einem Mondfahrzeug und sind da sehr ernst bei der Geschichte. Und damit hat sich das ergeben, dass wir dann über das DLR RMC in Oberpfaffenhofen wirklich eine Kooperation mit dem gesamten DLR gestartet haben. Und da ging es dann zum Beispiel darum, dass wir unseren Rover angepasst haben. Also wir haben dann zum Beispiel gesagt, okay, die Räder, die ihr habt, die sind ein bisschen klein, da glauben wir nicht, dass die funktioniert, macht die doch mal ein bisschen größer. Und wir haben dann deren Motortechnologie eingebaut. Wir haben beim Kamerakopf kooperiert, sodass es tatsächlich einen Rover gibt, wo der Kamerakopf austauschbar ist zwischen unserem Rover und deren Rover. Und auch bei der Ansteuerung und anderen Technologien haben wir uns sehr intensiv auseinander ausgetauscht und gemeinsam entwickelt.
Und Berührungsängste gab es da sozusagen gar nicht. Ich meine, es ist ja auch die Frage, wie sich so ihr Privatunternehmen und so öffentlich finanziertes System da zueinander stellen.
Eigentlich nicht, nee. Man muss halt ein bisschen unterscheiden. Es gibt da diese Ingenieursebene, wo das eigentlich immer prima funktioniert, weil da reden dann Ingenieure untereinander und kein Ingenieur will sagen, ich helfe dir nicht, weil du bist doof. Sondern jeder möchte sein Wissen einbringen. Und auf der Ebene funktioniert so eine Zusammenarbeit immer hervorragend. Und dann gibt es halt die Ebenen darüber mit der Bürokratie und der Organisation. Und da wird es dann kniffliger, sag ich jetzt mal.
Ich meine, da kommen dann so Fragen von Intellectual Property und Verträgen, Patenten etc. Alles zum Tragen, was natürlich im öffentlichen Teil irgendwie halt geregelt ist, aber dann nicht zwangsläufig immer so zur Wirtschaftslandschaft der Privaten passt, oder?
Genau, genau. Das ist dann immer der Teil, wo es dann irgendwie ein bisschen schwierig wird.
Aber nicht unmöglich. Also man hat da sozusagen ein Modus gefunden.
Nö, also das haben wir eigentlich, glaube ich, ganz gut hinbekommen. Also die vertraglichen Details dann irgendwie so auszuarbeiten, dass das für beide von Vorteil ist.
Was sind noch für Partner mit an Bord?
Naja, also...
Die wichtig sind? Die ist auch wirklich zum Projektbeitrag, meine ich.
Also wirklich wichtig ist natürlich für uns Audi, ganz klar. Die helfen uns bei der... Also eine der wichtigsten Dinge, die sie unserem Mondfahrzeug jetzt beigetragen haben, ist, dass sie es geschafft haben, wirklich 10 kg runterzuholen. Also das ist wirklich eine ganze Menge. Der Rover ist ein bisschen größer geworden noch und trotzdem 10 kg leichter. Und das ist halt einfach durch diesen Aluleichtbau mit 3D-gedrucktem Aluminium, haben wir das geschafft, das Gewicht runterzuholen. Wir haben auch die Geländefähigkeit ein bisschen verbessert.
Und 10 kg, muss man dazu sagen, ist in Weltraubendimension eine Menge Holz.
Richtig, genau.
Also ich rechne mal jetzt so 8 Millionen Euro weniger Kosten.
Also so kann man das rechnen. Also es ist ja so, dass wir auf Alina quasi kommerzielle Payload anbieten. Das heißt, jemand kann bei uns mitfliegen gegen Geld. Und 1 kg kostet dann 800.000 Euro. Und wenn wir dann 10 kg an unserem Rover einsparen, können wir die 10 kg verkaufen für 800.000, was dann quasi 8 Millionen werden. Man kann es aber auch andersherum rechnen. Eines der Grundprobleme der Raumfahrt ist ja, dass man sich eine Rakete auswählen muss. Und die gibt es halt in verschiedenen Größen. Wir haben unsere Mission darauf ausgelegt, dass wir mit einer der gut kommerzialisierten Satellitenraketen fliegen können. Wir hätten ja auch einfach eine sehr viel größere Rakete nehmen können. So eine Ariane 5 ist gemütlich, passt unsere Mission locker rein, aber die kostet auch dann ein paar hundert Millionen. Wir haben also versucht, eine möglichst kleine Landefähre zu bauen, mit dem kleinsten möglichen Rover, der wir denken, dass er sinnvoll auf der Oberfläche funktionieren kann. Wenn wir jetzt zehn Kilogramm auf unserem Rover drauf haben, bedeutet das, dass wir effektiv das Zehnfache davon an Sprit mitnehmen müssen. Was bedeuten kann, dass wir den nächstgrößeren Tank nehmen müssen. Das kann dazu führen, dass wir so groß werden, dass wir nicht mehr in diese kleinen Raketen reinpassen, was dazu führt, dass wir auf einmal anstatt ein paar 10 Millionen, ein paar 100 Millionen für die Rakete finanzieren müssen. Das ist ein sehr komplexes System, was wir da haben, wo kleine Änderungen auf der Rover-Seite oder der Alina-Seite sehr große Änderungen im Budget nach sich ziehen können. Von daher lohnt es sich dann doch schon mal, ein bisschen Ressourcen da rein zu verschwenden, um Gewicht zu sparen.
Das heißt, Audi war insofern eigentlich ein idealer Partner, konkret mit diesem Material, also mit Aluminium. Bauform ist ja im Prinzip auch ein kleines Auto. Da einfach viele Erfahrungen hatten, die ihr jetzt sicherlich auch irgendwann mal vielleicht hätte aufbauen können, aber eben nicht in diesem Zeitrahmen.
Genau, und Audi hat natürlich noch irgendwelche Testinfrastruktur, also irgendwelche Shaker, wo man mal Dinge vibrieren lassen kann. Wir waren vor kurzem in der Sonnenkammer, wo man die Solarpanel vermessen kann, wie die sich verhalten bei verschiedenen Sonnenstärken und Richtungen und Temperaturen. Und auch Materialanalysen und solche Geschichten. Die haben halt wahnsinnige Infrastruktur, die wir halt auch mitnützen können. Und das ist halt für uns natürlich extrem von Vorteil. Also das würde ich halt auch sagen. Vor allem ist es ein Gewinn für die Raumfahrt als Ganzes. Weil wir als Unternehmen quasi dabei sind, zu zeigen, dass es nicht nur staatliche Missionen geben muss, sondern dass es auch Unternehmen gibt, die so eine Mission unterstützen können, die vorher überhaupt gar nichts mit der Raumfahrt zu tun haben. Also Audi ist nicht für ihre Mondfahrzeuge bekannt. Zumindest noch nicht. Und da kommt dann quasi auch neue Gelder in die Raumfahrt rein. Und natürlich hat Audi auch ein bisschen Interesse daran, das dann öffentlich bekannt zu geben, was sie da tun, was dann auch wieder Werbung für die Raumfahrt ist als solche.
Weitere Kooperationspartner, die noch erwähnenswert sind? Ihr kooperiert, glaube ich, mit Unis noch?
Genau, wir haben eine ganze Liste an Unis, wo ich jetzt hoffentlich komplett aufzähle. Wir haben die Uni Würzburg, wir haben die TU Berlin, wir haben die TU Hamburg, die Uni Basel unterstützt uns teilweise. Und ich hoffe, ich habe jetzt keinen vergessen. Bestimmt. Aber was heißt das?
Was heißt die Uni unterstützt? Was für eine Art Relationship ist das?
Also zum Beispiel bei der Uni Würzburg ist es so, dass die uns ganz konkret bei der Software für Alina, auch für unseren Rover unterstützen. Also wir nutzen ein RODOS, das ist so ein Betriebssystem, das halt von Herrn Montenegro damals beim DLR entwickelt wurde. Und er ist jetzt an der Uni Würzburg und setzt... Hat aber nichts mit DOS zu tun.
Nee, hoffe ich. Hab ich das noch nicht gehört?
Nee, ist halt eher so ein spezialisiertes...
Also ein Rechtsalzsystem für Embedded Systems.
Genau. Speziell für Satellitenmissionen entwickelt. Und das nutzen wir zum Beispiel auf Alina und auf...
Okay, vom DLR tatsächlich auch.
Genau. Und ja, also an der Uni Basel geht es zum Beispiel darum, wir haben halt in einer Halle ein 10x20 Meter Testbett, wo wir eine bestimmte Eifellava aufgeschüttet haben, die dem Untergrund des Mondes entspricht, sodass wir dort mit unserem Rover herumfahren können und gucken, ob das mit der Traktion und so weiter, ob das Mobilitätskonzept einfach gut funktioniert. Und da haben die uns dann beraten, welche Lava man dann nimmt und welche jetzt dem Mond am ähnlichsten ist, also diese geologischen Eigenschaften. Von dem Regolith, genau.
Okay, also mit anderen Worten ist auch kein Fehler, quasi sowohl zu den klassischen Raumfahrtbetreibern und Wissenschaftsorganisationen wie auch den Universitäten Verbindung zu halten. Weil, da wollte ich auch gleich nochmal drüber reden, gerade der Aspekt Software. Jetzt habt ihr schon eine relativ hohe Softwarelastigkeit im Team. Tatsächlich ist ja Software Engineering auch so ein Thema. Das hat man jetzt ja gerade vor ein paar Wochen wieder gesehen, als eine Teilmission des ExoMars-Projekts dummerweise gescheitert ist und wie es aussieht, so was ich zumindest verstanden habe bisher, auf Basis eines Software-Fehlers im Prinzip, also einer Fehlinterpretation der Sensordaten. Kann ja mal vorkommen, ist dann halt blöd, wenn man nur einen Schuss hat. Aber ist ja jetzt auch nicht ohne Vorläufer. Also man hat ja oft gesehen, dass Missionen im Prinzip ist alles richtig gebaut gewesen. Klar, mal fährt ein Motor nicht aus, mal bleibt was stecken, mal hat irgendwas unter Strahlenbeschuss groß gelitten. Teilweise auch die Computer selbst. Aber mit Software kann man halt einerseits eine Menge rausholen. Auf der anderen Seite kann man aber auch etwas nicht funktionieren lassen, was sonst vielleicht hätte funktionieren können, wenn man es denn nur richtig angesteuert hat. Das ist eine spezielle Herausforderung, hier die Software für diese Systeme zu machen. Ich sage das gerade, wir leben so in einer Zeit, wo wir jetzt gerade merken, auf Wire vielleicht ist unser bisheriger Ansatz nicht der richtige gewesen. In den 80er, 90er, auch noch in den 2000er Jahren, ja, man lädt sich alles runter, Programme stürzen ab, ja kein Problem, kann man ja wieder neu starten und so. Und das sind natürlich so Dinge, die gehen so um all, nicht so ohne weiteres und schon gar nicht bei solchen kritischen Missionen, wie wir landen jetzt mal, weil Neustart beim Landen, ja, haben wir gelacht. Welchen Ansatz verfolgt ihr da sozusagen, um diese Software-Entwicklung auch wirklich auf hochsolide Füße zu stellen?
Also das ist wirklich eine extrem große Herausforderung und man kann da auch beliebig Ressourcen reinstecken. Und das ist ja auch das, was ESA gemacht hat. Die haben halt schöne Simulationsmodelle gehabt, die aber dann halt auch nicht die Wirklichkeit wiedergeben. Und das ist das Grundproblem der Software-Entwicklung, dass der erste Test in einer realen Umgebung mit allen Parametern genau dann stattfindet, wenn man es durchführt. Und da gibt es halt wirklich sehr viele verschiedene Philosophien. Also die eine Philosophie ist, man versucht halt wirklich, man macht so eine formale Software-Verifikation, dass man wirklich versucht zu zeigen, dass das korrekt ist.
Also beweisbarer Code.
Genau, beweisbarer Code. Wobei das Lustige war, an der TU Hamburg war eine neue Professorenstelle ausgeschrieben. Und da war einer, der wollte formale Verifikationen als sein Hauptthema einbringen. Und hat dann vorgestellt, dass er so ein Projekt gemacht hat, wo es darum geht, irgendwie so ein Modulo 3000-Operation zu machen. Und er hat wunderbar bewiesen, was er da zeigen wollte. Außer, dass die Operation, die er da bewiesen hat, war ein Modulo 2999 und nicht ein Modulo 3000. Weil er das falsch verstanden hat, wie das Modulo funktioniert. Also formale Verifikation ist halt auch nur so gut, wie die Anforderungen, die man reingibt. Und das ist wirklich das Grundproblem. Man kann sich Modelle überlegen, die immer eine Vereinfachung sind, aber nie die komplette Realität widerspiegeln werden. Man wird nie das richtige Rauschen der Sensoren haben. Man wird nie die unbedachten Dinge drin haben, dass der Sensor irgendeinen Quatsch macht. Es wird immer ein Problem sein. Unsere Philosophie ist es, dass wir, dadurch dass wir unsere eigene Hardware entwickelt haben, dass wir versuchen, möglichst wenig verschiedene Komponenten einzusetzen. Zum Beispiel der Bordcomputer von Alina, das ist auch der Bordcomputer von unseren Rovern, der auch der Bordcomputer ist, der die Kamerabilder annimmt. Wir versuchen, einen Teil zu machen, den wir dann wirklich sehr, sehr gut testen können und auch sehr häufig testen, weil wir den einfach sehr häufig in Systemen drin haben. Wir versuchen halt wirklich, viele Systeme immer wieder zu benutzen. Das ist zum Beispiel auch ein Grundproblem, wenn man jetzt sagt, wir kaufen uns einen Bordcomputer für 150.000 Euro ein. Dann hat man eine Platine, die ist heilig, die liegt dann bei einem Software-Entwickler auf dem Schreibtisch. Dann kann dieser eine Software-Entwickler damit arbeiten. Aber wenn man jetzt eine Platine hat, die 500 Euro kostet, dann bestellt man sich halt zehn von den Dingern, dann hat jeder Software-Entwickler die gleiche Platine. Und jeder Software-Entwickler kann damit so lange rumspielen und testen, wie er möchte. Und dadurch geht dann quasi die Testzeit hoch.
Oder auch die Hardware.
Richtig, genau. Also der Kostenfaktor ist halt auch ein anderer Aspekt. Also unsere Mission ist halt zwar in einem zweistelligen Millionenbereich, aber halt nicht in einem dreistelligen Millionenbereich. Das heißt, wenn wir, also ich glaube der Lunalender, der sollte mehr als 300 Millionen kosten. Ich glaube es waren sogar 600 Millionen. Und da würden wir unsere Mission irgendwie zwischen 5 und 10 Mal reinpassen.
Das heißt, auf welchen Lunalender beziehst du dich jetzt?
Den europäischen Lunalender, der jetzt die letzte Mondmission, die quasi abgesagt wurde. Wir könnten quasi effektiv unsere Mission 5 Mal fliegen, davon 4 Mal crashen und wären kostenmäßig immer noch effektiver als die eine Mission. Praktisch, ob das dann mit der Finanzierung wirklich so funktioniert, ist eine ganz andere Frage. Und ob der politische Gegenwind, den man da bekommt, ist halt auch noch eine andere Geschichte. Aber zum Beispiel als SpaceX die erste Falcon 1 entwickelt hat, haben die auch fünf Fehlschläge gehabt, bevor die erstmal in den Low Earth Orbit reingekommen sind und haben für wenige hundert Millionen eine Falcon 9 Rakete entwickelt, die jetzt effektiv dem Stand der Ariane 6 ungefähr entspricht, die jetzt gerade 1,7 Milliarden an Entwicklungsgeldern zugesprochen bekommen haben. Also es ist einfach eine andere Herangehensweise, die man an den Tag legt, wenn das die eigenen Gelder sind, mit denen man da hantiert.
Ja, weil man eine ganz andere Verantwortung gegenüber dem Projekt natürlich auch spürt.
Genau, aber wir können auch ganz andere Risiken eingehen. Wir sind nicht von einem Politiker abhängig, der im nächsten Jahr wiedergewählt werden muss. Es ist halt einem Steuerklärer schwer zu erzählen, dass diese 50 Millionen, die man da gerade in den Mars oder in den Mond gesetzt hat, nur ein Zehntel von dem waren, was eine andere Mission mit einer höheren Ausfallwahrscheinlichkeit gekostet hätte. Das ist halt das Problem der Politik. Wir können, solange wir Gelder finden aus dem privaten Umfeld, können wir unsere Missionen durchziehen, wie wir wollen.
Also günstige Plattformen habe ich verstanden. Und auch so anspruchsvolle Systeme wie formale Softwareverifikationen sind nicht unbedingt ein Garant, dass immer alles super funktioniert. Aber irgendwie muss man ja dann sich doch Gedanken darüber machen, wie man seine Software so entwickelt, dass sie wirklich zuverlässig ist. Kannst du da mal einen Einblick geben, was ihr da so für Überlegungen angestellt habt?
Also zum Beispiel, also eine der wirklich kritischen Phasen ist ja effektiv der Landeanflug, wo wir wissen müssen, wo wir uns befinden und dann auf dem Mond an einer relativ speziellen Stelle landen wollen. Wenn man jetzt sagen würde, es ist egal, wo wir landen, könnte man ja auch dieses Sojourner-Prinzip machen, dass man einfach irgendwie mal hinfliegt und einfach mit einem Abstandsmesser dann das testet. Also wir wollen an einer bestimmten Stelle landen. Und da ist dann die Frage, wie testet man dann diese Navigation? Und da gibt es zum Beispiel vom DLR das Projekt ATON, wo die sich dann an einer Wand ein Relief, ich weiß nicht, ob das gedruckt oder gefräst ist, aber auf jeden Fall sehr detailliert eine Mondlandschaft nachgebaut haben, wo man mit der Seite reinleuchtet und dann mit einer echten Kamera quasi das Landemanöver simuliert. Das Ganze kann man natürlich auch nochmal in Software machen. Dann kann man das Ganze auch noch mit einer Drohne machen, dass man mit einer Drohne fliegt und Bilder von oben macht. Aber das Problem ist, the real deal, das geschieht halt wirklich erst, wenn man das erste Mal hinfliegt und dann Daten drunter überträgt. Der Mond ist eigentlich hervorragend kategografiert. Insbesondere von der Apollo-17-Landestelle gibt es wirklich extrem viele Daten. Das war auch eine der Gründe, warum wir die uns ausgesucht haben. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man dort auf einen großen Stein landet, ist einfach relativ gering. Also wir haben uns halt eine Stelle gegeben.
Weil es da so wenig davon gibt.
Genau, da gibt es wenig große Steine. Da gibt es halt viele kleine Steine, aber die sind für unsere Landung jetzt weniger kritisch. Das ist dann zum Beispiel so etwas, dass man sich die Rahmenbedingungen vereinfacht. Dass man nicht versucht, einfach am Südpol zu landen, wo das Landen wirklich extrem kritisch ist, weil die Lichtverhältnisse total doof sind. Wenn man daneben liegt, dann sitzt man im permanenten Schatten. Wir haben uns in einer Equator-Region gesucht, die extrem gutes Kartenmaterial hat, wo wir wissen, wie man da landen kann und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man nicht in einem Krater oder auf einem großen Stein landet, relativ gering ist.
Wie macht man jetzt deine Software da dicht?
Das Grundprinzip ist, dass man ein Matlab-Modell hat, mit dem man dann die Bildverarbeitung reinzieht. Dann testet man das mit diesen simulierten Daten, ob das Modell das macht, was man sich vorstellt. Dann versucht man, mit Sensorrauschen herauszufinden, wie groß die Varianz der Landelipse ist. Wie gesagt, das sind halt alles Modelle und nicht die Wahrheit.
Ihr geht da sozusagen optisch ran. Ihr habt Kameras im Lander und hier an der Stelle ist es im Wesentlichen Image-Processing. Also man versucht, mit der Software zu gucken. Aber wie überprüft ihr die Software? Geht es nur darum, wir lassen das jetzt eine Million mal durch simulieren mit allen möglichen Bildern und legen da noch ein Rauschen drüber und dann gucken wir mal, ob wir immer wieder aufs gleiche Ergebnis kommen?
Wir haben uns wirklich sehr lange damit auseinandergesetzt, wie man das testen kann. Wir haben uns ganz wilde Geschichten überlegt, also dass man halt mit einer Drohne, mit einem gedruckten Mondspiel fällt, dass man dann versucht, mit der Drohne zu landen und da die Navigation mit teste, das ist aber auch alles schwierig. Und man führt halt neue Störquellen ein, die man auf dem Mond effektiv auch gar nicht so hat. Also es ist wirklich extrem schwierig.
Hat ja auch keiner gesagt, dass es leicht wird.
Genau, also das ist halt das Grundproblem. Also wenn man in diesem Simulationsmodell halt einen Parameter falsch angenommen hat, dann kracht man halt in den Boden rein. So wie es halt bei der ESA-Mission auch passiert ist.
Genau, bei dem Skia-Parelli-Lander. Dann kommen wir nochmal auf die eigentliche Missionsplanung. Also das wird ja auch oft übersehen, dass das eigentlich erstmal am Anfang steht. Vielleicht kannst du nochmal kurz skizzieren, was soll passieren? Also wie ich es bisher verstanden habe, Rakete, ihr steckt euren Lander rein, in dem Lander sind zwei Rover.
Richtig, genau.
Zwei. Und startet, fliegt los, dann wird es irgendwie eine Trennung geben. Ab da müsst ihr ja im Prinzip selber die Kontrolle übernehmen.
Das macht ihr dann von wo aus?
Also wir werden unser Mission Control Zentrum bei uns in unserer Halle aufbauen und sind dann per Internet quasi mit S-Track verbunden, die uns dann die Daten liefern vom Spacecraft. Also ein bisschen besseres Internet.
Besseres Internet? Also ich vermute mal, das sind schon speziell geschützte Leitungen, die sozusagen eine andere Zuverlässigkeitsgarantie haben dürfen.
Natürlich, klar. Auf jeden Fall. Also wir haben da gute Anbieter, die uns auch eine Leitung zur Verfügung stellen können, die jetzt nicht ausfallen wird. Also die eine sehr geringe Auswahlwahrscheinlichkeit hat.
Stehen da auch gleich so die Stormtrooper bereit in dem Fall, wo es auch nur, welche Garantie kann man sozusagen bekommen? Also ich meine, man behauptet so 99,9 Prozent, das wäre eine tolle Ansage. Aber wenn man das mal so auf die Jahrestage hochrechnet, ist ja schon ein Tag Blackout. Das muss ja eher so 5, 6, 7, 8 Stellen hinter dem Komma sein.
Also es gibt da so die Auswahlwahrscheinlichkeit, die wir anstreben, ist drei Stunden pro Jahr. Das ist aber auch nur, wir haben verschiedene Links. Wir haben einmal so eine Glasfaser, wir haben dann DSL, wir haben LTE und da haben wir schon mal ein bisschen Streuung. Und dann haben wir noch einen zweiten Standort, der auch als Backup fungieren kann. Also wenn wir dann wirklich ein komplettes Blackout haben, kann man komplett umschalten. Also das ist halt zum Beispiel sowas, was wir halt auch ein bisschen anders machen. Wir bekommen die Daten von S-Track, gehen zum einen an unser Mission Control Zentrum, wo dann der Server steht, der die Verarbeitung macht, und zum anderen an einen Cloud-Anbieter, wo wir die Software auch hosten. Und vom Prinzip her ist die Software so, dass wir mit jedem Browser, von jedem Terminal, darauf zugreifen können. Das heißt, wenn wirklich alles schief geht, dann könnte man auch von einem iPad aus, von einem Auto aus die Mission steuern. Natürlich, selbstverständlich. Die Grundabsicherung über VPNs ist natürlich immer klar.
Also das heißt, kann man schon etwas dazu sagen, womit vermutlich geflogen werden wird, oder ist das noch unklar?
Also wir haben eine Rakete geboten bei einem Broker. Das ist so eine Art Mitfahrgelegenheit. Wir teilen uns die Rakete mit einem anderen Satellitenhersteller. Wir wissen auch schon, welche Rakete das sehr wahrscheinlich sein wird. Aber das Interessante für uns ist, dass SpaceX oder die United Launch Alliance zur Auswahl stehen. Theoretisch, wenn SpaceX noch ein paar Mal explodiert, werden wir mit der United Launch Alliance starten. Aber momentan gibt es unser präferiertes Launch-Vehicle, das ist eine Falcon 9. Richtig, das ist eine der Besonderheiten von Alina. Wir wurden schon öfters enttäuscht. Als wir ganz am Anfang gestartet sind, und in der Präsentation von 2009 ist das sogar noch drin, dass wir auf der Falcon 1E fliegen von SpaceX, die dann abgekündigt wurde. Das heißt, wir haben unsere Länder entwickelt für eine Rakete, die dann abgekündigt wurde. Na ja, die Falcon 1 wurde ja, nachdem sie erfolgreich etwas in den Leo gebracht hatte, effektiv eingestellt, wurde dann durch die Falcon 9 ersetzt. Und würde auch so nicht mehr angeboten werden. Genau, es scheint kein interessanter Markt für SpaceX zu sein. Dann haben wir uns gesagt, dann nehmen wir halt die russische Tnepr-Rakete. Das ist so eine ehemalige Interkontinental-Rakete. Dann nehmen wir den Atomsprengkorb raus und tun dann unsere Mondmission rein. Wir würden dann aus einem Silo heraus, das finde ich ziemlich cool, aus einem Silo heraus in den Low Earth Orbit kommen. Dann kam die Ukraine-Krise. Das heißt, noch eine neue Länder-Iteration, auch wieder für den Papierkorb entwickelt. Das war der Zeitpunkt, wo wir uns gesagt haben, dieses Spielchen ist doof, das wollen wir nicht weiter mitmachen. Wir haben mit Alina eine modulare Plattform entwickelt, die verschiedene Orbit-Anforderungen erfüllen kann. Das heißt, wir können von einem sehr niedrigen GTO aus fliegen, wir können von einem super GTO aus fliegen, also von einem sehr hohen Orbit, und von quasi jedem zwischendrin. Das ermöglicht uns, weil wir auch ein besonders kleines Raumschiff haben, dass wir zum Beispiel auch von der indischen PSLV XL fliegen können, aber halt natürlich auch mit den standardamerikanischen und europäischen Raketen. Das gibt uns die Flexibilität, dass wir mit verschiedenen Launch-Providern gleichzeitig reden können. Das heißt, wir haben mit den Indern geredet, wir haben auch mit SpaceX geredet und haben mit denen verhandelt und können die ein bisschen gegeneinander ausspielen. Wir können sagen, wir machen die sauber billiger, die haben uns das angeboten und da kriegen wir das extra Gudi dazu.
Klar, es ist natürlich immer ein Vorteil, wenn man nicht festgelegt ist. Kurze Nachfrage, GTO, was meinst du noch mit?
Das ist der Geo-Transfer-Orbit. Also wenn man einen Satelliten in einen geostationären Orbit bringen möchte, dann macht man das über den GTO. Die Elipse, die wir haben werden, ist 32.000 mal 300 Kilometer.
32.000 mal 300. 300 bezieht sich jetzt auf die Höhe?
Also 300 ist die, wie heißen die Punkte? Das ist der niedrigste Punkt hinter der Erde quasi. 63.000 ist der höchste Punkt.
63.000?
32.000. Genau, 63.000 ist ein anderer Orbit, den wir angeboten bekommen haben. Aber unsere Mitfahrgelegenheit möchte lieber in den 32.000.
Also das heißt, der GTO ist sozusagen so eine ellipsoide Umringung des Planeten. Ich glaube, die Begriffe, die du gesucht hast, Perihel und...
Genau, Apogeum.
Apogeum, wo ich immer wieder verwechselte, welcher welcher ist.
Ich weiß das auch nie. Zum Glück nicht die Flugbahnberechnung. Dafür haben wir Leute, die kennen sich damit viel besser aus.
Warum ist das eigentlich ellipsoid?
Naja, also die geostationären Satelliten, die wollen ja dann effektiv auf eine 63.000 Kilometer Höhe, um dann über der gleichen Stelle auf der Erde... Entschuldigung, ja. Genau, um dann wirklich da zu bleiben. Die machen das halt über diese ellipsoide Geschichte, weil die Rakete, bei der Beschleunigung, da kommt halt ein Ellipsoid raus. Der muss dann erst zirkularisiert werden, der Orbit. Also das ist so ein Höhlemann-Manöver, wo man dann das, was haben wir gerade gesagt, Perigeum, so lange erhöht, bis man auf der Zielebene ist, wo man dann zirkularisiert.
So, also mit anderen Worten, ihr seid ja flexibel. Es könnte sozusagen unterschiedliche Einschüsse geben, aber wo es auch noch mal genau ist, das Ding treibt sich quasi erst mal um die Erde herum mit so einem Ellipsoiden, auf so einer Ellipsoiden-Orbit-Bahn.
Genau.
Und dann, worauf, also vor allem, das ist ja sozusagen genau der Moment, wo dann quasi ihr als Payload der Rakete abgesetzt werdet. Also der eigentliche Länder ist dann quasi alles, was noch fliegt, richtig? Oder gibt es da noch mal was drum herum?
Nee, nee, also es ist so, dass Alina ist quasi unser Landemodul und auch unser Transfermodul. Das heißt, von diesem GTO machen wir dann mit verschiedenen Burns erhöhen wir dann immer die Flugbahn.
Das heißt, man gibt immer wieder ein bisschen Saft dazu und verstärkt immer wieder diese Ellipse?
Genau, bis man dann auf einer Ellipse ist, die halt 380.000 Kilometer hoch ist. Und dann kommt man halt dann, wenn der Mond dann richtig am richtigen Zeitpunkt genau da ist, wird man halt von der Gravitation des Mondes eingefangen und kommt dann in einen Mondorbit, den man dann auch erst noch mal zirkularisieren muss. Und dann sind wir dann in einem Orbit um den Mond, von dem wir aus dann sagen, ok, jetzt sind alle Systeme go und dann starten wir die Landung.
Ok, bevor wir dahin kommen. Also in diesem GTO, in diesem Transferorbit, nachdem man abgesetzt ist, also quasi jetzt nur Alina und die Rover an Bord. Die Rover schlummern wahrscheinlich erstmal in Ruhe vor sich hin, werden wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen getestet, aber anderes Thema. Mich interessiert jetzt erst nochmal die Kommunikation. Also ihr müsst ja dann quasi mit diesem Ding auch reden. Es gibt dann nach dem Start immer diesen spannenden Moment der Übergabe. Lebt das Ding noch? Können wir mit dem reden? Schon so ein paar Mal mitbekommen, weil ihr seht, das sind immer so die Schweißperlen-Momente, wo man dann so, hm, lebt es noch? Weil ist ja jetzt auch kein, wie soll ich sagen, ist ja kein Zuckerschlecken so ein Start. Da wird ja alles komplett durchgerüttelt und ist also extrem Vibrationen und Beschleunigungskräften ausgesetzt. Und wenn das halt alles nicht ordentlich zusammengeschraubt war oder überhaupt nicht in der richtigen Statik berechnet war, kann es ja schon mal sein, dass etwas Schaden nimmt, kann sein, dass die Kommunikation Schaden nimmt, kann sein, dass irgendwelche Sensoren danach vielleicht nicht mehr funktionieren. Das heißt, ab diesem Moment müsst ihr ja quasi als Mission Control dann auch selber übernehmen. So, und diese Übergabe erfolgt dann quasi von dem Launcher, also bis dahin ist quasi die Rakete, das Ding wird ausgesetzt, aber eure Signale werden dann über das S-TRAC-Netzwerk quasi empfangen. Das heißt, ihr benutzt quasi S-TRAC als Satellitenfühler oder sozusagen als Kommunikationsoutlet.
Also genau, also S-TRAC besteht ja aus mehreren großen Schüsseln, die über die ganze Welt verteilt sind, und die werden dann als erstes versuchen, aufgrund der Orbital-Daten, die wir von dem Launch-Provider bekommen, versuchen, mit Alina in Kommunikation zu treten. Und wenn wir das dann gemacht haben, dann gibt es natürlich erstmal die obligatorischen System-Checks, und dann geht es eigentlich auch schon relativ schnell weiter. Also da wird eigentlich nicht so viel gewartet, sage ich jetzt mal. Das hängt immer, welche Orbits wir genau brauchen, hängt halt davon ab, an welchem Tag wir genau starten. Wir müssen halt ein Startfenster anbieten, über mehrere Tage, wo es über mehrere Stunden möglich ist, zu starten. Und je nachdem, wo genau, an welchem Tag, zu welcher Uhrzeit wir starten, müssen wir dann eventuell so eine Art Warte-Orbit einlegen, damit dann der Mond auf der richtigen Ebene, am richtigen Punkt für uns vorbeikommt. Vollmond ist ja quasi, wenn man sich jetzt den Mond mal einfach anschaut, dann sind wir so ein bisschen oben rechts vom Mittelpunkt. Und das heißt, der ideale Zeitpunkt ist nach dem Neumond, ich glaube, das sind drei Tage nach dem Neumond, ist der optimale Zeitpunkt, wo wir mit dem Landen beginnen, wo die Landestelle dann langsam anfängt beleuchtet zu werden. Die Sonne auch noch einen bestimmten Winkel hat. Also wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel bei Mittag, also Vollmond, landen würden, dann hätten wir das Problem, dass wir Krater nicht mehr erkennen können, weil die Sonne ja direkt von oben drauf...
Ach so, weil es keinen Schattenwurf besteht? Genau.
Das heißt, es gibt nach dem Aufgang einen optimalen Zeitpunkt, wo der Schattenwurf so gut ist, dass wir genau wissen, jetzt können wir die Krater gut erkennen, die wir zur Navigation brauchen. Und das ist dann ein paar Tage nach dem Neumond.
Das heißt, das Launch-Window, wo man starten will, ist eigentlich noch so abnehmender Mond, kurz vor Neumond ein paar Tage?
Ungefähr, ja.
So ungefähr, genau, kann man das wahrscheinlich gar nicht sagen. Dann muss man unter Umständen noch mal ein, zwei Tage in diesem GTO verweilen, um sozusagen den richtigen Moment abzuwarten. Und wenn dieser richtige Moment gekommen ist, dann drückt man noch mal aufs Gas. Und damit ist quasi die Beschleunigung des Raumfahrtobjekts stärker als die Bindung an die Schwerkraft der Erde, weil dann auch noch die Schwerkraft des Mondes quasi mitzieht.
Ja, die ist aber für den großen Teil des Fluges vernachlässigbar.
Sie spielt jetzt auch nicht keine Rolle. Also man gibt halt einmal Gas, entflieht quasi der Erde und lässt sich dann aber mittelfristig auch wieder vom Mond einfangen.
Genau. Wobei das Ganze natürlich noch komplizierter ist. Man hat verschiedene Orbitalplanen. Man fliegt ja in einem bestimmten Winkel um die Erde herum. Das ist der Winkel zum Äquator. Genau. Und dann der Mond hat auch einen bestimmten Winkel, der jetzt zum Beispiel von der Jahreszeit dann auch abhängt. Also dann müssen wir genau an dem Schnittpunkt von diesen beiden Orbitalplanen quasi unsere Translunar Injection durchführen, dass wir dann wirklich in den Mondorbit hineinkommen. Aber ich glaube, als Technikinformatiker muss ich jetzt sagen, wenn ich hier irgendwann Quatsch erzähle, wir haben da die Experten, die das berechnen und ich bin keiner von denen.
Na gut, aber es ist ja auch schon mal ganz interessant zu wissen, dass solche Fragen überhaupt mit bedacht werden müssen.
Auf jeden Fall. Das ist ein hochkomplexes und auch sehr spannendes Thema.
Man kann nicht irgendwie da mal hinfliegen, sondern man muss sich extrem darüber Gedanken machen, wie ist die Konstellation des Mondes zur Erde? Was sind die Lichtverhältnisse zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo man da ankommt? Weil die Lichtverhältnisse halt unter anderem eben wichtig sind. Also einerseits will man natürlich dann Licht haben, um einfach die Solarpanele auch nutzen zu können. Andererseits will man auch Schatten haben, zumindest für die Landung, einfach damit man was sieht, weil ansonsten dieser ganze Regulizand wahrscheinlich fast wie eine weiße Fläche vor einem steht.
Also das ist zum Beispiel auch eine der Probleme, die wir halt irgendwie so herausbekommen haben. Also wir haben uns tatsächlich mit Gene Cernan und Jack Schmidge getroffen. Das sind ja die beiden Apollo-Astronauten, die da oben herumgefahren sind. Dann haben die halt gefragt, was eigentlich die größte Herausforderung ist, auf dem Mond herumzufahren. Und die haben gesagt, dass man gegen Mittag halt nicht mehr so viel Kontrast sieht. Also dass man, dann sieht man diese Schlaglöcher quasi nicht mehr so. Das heißt, es kann dann passieren, dass man mal schneller in so einen Grad da reinfällt. Das andere Problem, was man hat, ist...
Also gegen Mittag ist jetzt nicht ein 24-Stunden-Zyklus?
Genau, also Mittag ist dann 7 Tage. Also wir haben ja, ein halber Monat ist ja quasi, ist ja komplette Tag. Und in der Mitte des Tages ist ja dann ein Viertel. Also auf jeden Fall da...
Also Mittag ist 7 Tage lang, sozusagen, gefühlt. Oder zumindest einige Tage lang.
Genau, ja. Und da ist es dann halt schwierig, die genauen Konturen wahrzunehmen. Und eine andere Schwierigkeit, die man hat, ist, dass man die Distanz nicht richtig einschätzt. Es gibt da oben ja nichts, was man kennt. Und dann einzuschätzen, oh, dieser Stein, der ist jetzt aber... Da vorne können wir ja mal hinfahren. Und dann haben sie festgestellt, sind es doch länger unterwegs, als sie es gedacht haben. Weil das ist nicht nur ein Stein, das ist ein halber Berg. Und das sind so die Schwierigkeiten, mit denen man zu kämpfen hat. Und natürlich die Signallaufzeit. Also es dauert ja anderthalb Sekunden, bis das Signal von der Erde auf den Mond ankommt. Und dann nochmal anderthalb Sekunden, bis man sieht, was man gemacht hat. Ja, aber das Gute ist, die Russen haben vor etlichen Jahrzehnten gezeigt, dass das möglich ist. Also die sind ja mit Lunar Hot da schon auf den Mond herumgefahren, als man auf einer Briefmarkengroßen Monitor das erkennen musste.
Ja, das war eine sehr erfolgreiche Mission. Ich glaube, das ist auch gerade noch der Rekordhalter der längsten Rover-Strecke, die so gefahren wurde. Oder haben die Amerikaner sie jetzt eingeholt? Jüngst, glaube ich, hat Opportunity das dann eingeholt, aber es hat halt auch ganz schön lang gedauert, das einzuholen. Okay, jetzt, ich wollte ja nochmal diesen Missionsablauf, einfach um nochmal irgendwie auch so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, was eigentlich da jetzt vor euch steht. Also wir hatten den Start, wir hatten die Übernahme, die Kommunikationsaufnahme via S-Track mit dem Modul. Man entscheidet sich dann eben für den richtigen Zeitpunkt der Entfernung von der Erde, fliegt rüber zum Mond, tritt dort in einen Orbit ein. Jetzt will man landen. Jetzt wissen wir, okay, der Mond ist jetzt sozusagen in seiner kurz nach Neumond-Phase ein paar Tage, drei, was auch immer Tage. Das heißt, es gibt einen gewissen Schattenwurf. Jetzt muss ja im Prinzip das komplette Raumfahrzeug landen. Ich kann mich noch ganz gut erinnern, als ich das erste Mal mit programmierbaren Computern zu tun hatte in 80er Jahren, da war so Lunar Lander das Game, das lief irgendwie überall. Was später dann Tetris war und heute gibt es ja andere Nachfolger. Lunar Lander, das war so das Demoprogramm, das musste irgendwie jeder bringen. Im Idealfall natürlich irgendwie halbwegs grafisch. Und dann hat man als Kind dann halt immer seine Zeit damit verbracht, so immer so ein bisschen Gas geben, um das Ding irgendwie hoch zu jagen. Das war sozusagen noch so die Auswirkungen der 60er, 70er Jahre, die dann noch zu spüren waren. Was sind denn jetzt so die realen Anforderungen, um so eine Landung gut zu machen? Also den optischen Teil haben wir jetzt schon mehrfach angesprochen. Man muss halt einfach mal hingucken. Aber das ist ja sicherlich nicht das Einzige, was an der Stelle berücksichtigt werden muss.
Ja, also es gibt da auch verschiedene Landemanöver. Also die russische Strategie ist quasi, dass man die Geschwindigkeit quasi komplett im Orbit versucht abzubauen und sich dann nur noch um die Vertikale kümmern muss.
Also man bremst sozusagen ab und fällt runter.
Effektiv, genau. Das ist quasi die besonders einfache Variante.
Das ist so, wie zum Beispiel Philae auf dem Kometen gelandet ist.
Grob vereinfacht, ja.
Das teilweise rausgeworfen wurde und dann eigentlich nur noch gefallen ist.
Ja, genau. Und das ist halt das Problem. Die hat dann relativ hohe Spritanforderungen, weil die nicht besonders effizient ist.
Man muss ja im Prinzip den gesamten Speed, den man so drauf hat, und der sollte ja möglichst hoch sein, damit man auch schnell landet, den muss man dann komplett wieder rausnehmen.
Genau. Und die bisschen effizientere Möglichkeit ist, dass man sagt, man hat einen Zero Velocity Approach, dass man sagt, man bremst die ganze Zeit und verliert dabei auch schon an Höhe, sodass die Geschwindigkeit, die man dann hat, wenn man auf der Oberfläche ist, idealerweise genau Null ist. Und das ist die ein bisschen anspruchsvollere Variante, die wir versuchen werden, die aber extrem spritzsparend ist, sage ich jetzt mal. Naja, die haben vom Prinzip her, die haben auch so, das glaube ich, so gemacht wie wir, effektiv. Aber die hatten auch einen menschlichen Piloten an Bord. Das hat die Sache natürlich ein bisschen vereinfacht. Das heißt, wir müssen quasi so einen Apollo-Astronauten auf einen Chip bringen, der dann da landet. Aber im Gegensatz zu so einer Mars-Mission haben wir den Vorteil, dass wir die Telemetrie annähernd live mitverfolgen können. Das heißt, wenn wir feststellen, okay, also unsere Software macht jetzt hier ganz groben Unfug, dann können wir noch versuchen einzugreifen.
Was ist die Laufzeit, die Signallaufzeit?
Also drei Sekunden.
Drei Sekunden Empfang.
Also eineinhalb Sekunden Sendung und Roundtrip.
Roundtrip, okay, hin und zurück. Also eineinhalb Sekunden bis zum Mond. Okay, da kann man noch was drehen.
Genau, also nicht in den letzten Sekunden natürlich, aber man hat ja vorher eine Orbit Determination gemacht, damit man weiß, wo man ist, und dann macht man halt eine Orbit Propagation. Das heißt, man versucht dann mit dem geänderten Vektor zu berechnen, wo man den dann lenden wird. Und wenn wir da dann grobe Abweichungen feststellen, dann gibt es noch Möglichkeiten einzugreifen.
Aber woher weiß man denn eigentlich genau, wo man ist? Also man kann ja jetzt nicht immer nur sagen, naja, vorhin waren wir ja noch da, dann sind wir jetzt wahrscheinlich dort. Ist da auch eine Sternenkamera an Bord? Schaut man nochmal umher und orientiert sich daran?
Naja, also die Sternenkamera sagt einem eigentlich hauptsächlich, in welcher Orientierung sich das Raumschiff befindet. Das Raumschiff selber kann eigentlich nicht feststellen, wo es exakt ist. Das ist also Teil von Atom, ist ja diese Absolutnavigation. Das heißt, man guckt auf die Karte und sagt, okay, ich bin jetzt über dieser Stelle auf dem Mond. Und wenn man dann das nochmal macht, dann weiß man, okay, ich bin jetzt an der Stelle über dem Mond. Dann kann man daraus eine Flugbahn berechnen. Das wäre quasi so eine Selbstnavigation. Aber wenn man in einem Orbit ist, ist es eigentlich wesentlich einfacher, dass man dafür die Ranging-Funktionen von S-Track benutzt, also die dann wirklich per Funk eine Peilung machen. Die dauert ein paar Minuten, aber dann weiß man auch wirklich relativ genau, auf welchem Orbit sich das Spacecraft jetzt gerade genau befindet.
Ich dachte, so mit der Sternenpeilung hätten wir ja dann auch so eine Verdeckung. Man sieht ja im Prinzip auch noch die Erde. Man sieht ja auch, welche Sterne man nicht sieht und so.
Aber das Problem ist, die Auflösung ist dafür einfach dann nicht hochgenommen.
Und dann weiß man auch nur, du bist beim Mond.
Genau, danke, das wusste ich auch schon vorher.
Also Peilung, selber mitrechnen und das Ganze dann kombinieren mit den Image-Daten.
Genau, und dann hat man natürlich noch die IMU, also die Inertial Navigation Measurement Unit, wo man dann weiß, welche Beschleunigungskräfte auf das Raumschiff gerade wirken. Genau, aber die driften halt auch, also die sind nicht 100% genau. Also je länger die letzte Peilung her ist von der Erde, und je mehr Manöver man in der Zwischenzeit gemacht hat, desto ungenauer ist natürlich die absolute Position, wo man weiß, wo man gerade ist.
Aber ist denn sozusagen die Bilderkennung, die dann stattfindet während der Landung, geht es da sozusagen nur darum, rauszufinden, wie nahe sind wir jetzt an der Erde, oder geht es da auch schon dabei zu erkennen, wo sind wir? Deswegen habe ich auch vorhin gefragt, wie gut ist der Mond kartografiert? Kann man quasi auf der Basis im Gerät, ohne noch mal extra Roundtrip, auch quasi sagen, na die Struktur kenne ich, das kann jetzt nur hier sein?
Ja, das ist genau der Hintergedanke hinter der Absolutnavigation. Dass du die Krater anschaust und sagst, okay, den Krater kenne ich, der ist da und da auf dem Mond, dann muss ich jetzt hier und da sein. Und auf Basis dieser Absolutnavigation wird dann die Trajektorie zum Landen korrigiert. Das geht natürlich nur bis einer gewissen Höhe. Dann sieht man nicht mehr genug, quasi. Dann gibt es dann die Relativnavigation, dass man versucht, aus den Bildern nur noch die Geschwindigkeit über den Grund und den Abstand zum Grund zu berechnen. Und dann muss man halt versuchen, wirklich das Spacecraft stabil zu halten, um dann das Soft Landing hinzubekommen. Wobei Soft Landing auch bedeutet, dass wir das effektiv aus 6 m Höhe auf den Boden fallen lassen können.
Können aber nicht, wenn wir den wollen.
6 m ist ganz gut. Also das geht ganz gut. Also es entspricht 1 m ungefähr hier auf der Erde. Das muss unser Spacecraft aushalten.
Na okay, 1 m kann man sich noch ganz gut... Man muss ja auch berücksichtigen, dass die Mondanziehungskraft halt sehr viel geringer ist. Was ist das?
Also 0,6, also es ist ein Sechstel von der Erd.
Ein Sechstel ist es, ah okay. Ja, da kann man schön hüpfen. Ich hab das ja mal in so einem Flugzeug für 20 Sekunden gespürt, die passende Anziehungskraft. Das war sehr unterhaltsam.
Ja, wir haben auch irgendwie das Angebot bekommen, dass wir sowas mal machen. Und ich würde es auch echt gerne mal ausprobieren, aber ich glaube, ich möchte dann lieber das auf dem Mond ausprobieren. Also da kann man ja auch lustige machen. Ich habe gehört, dass man, wenn man jetzt in so einem Dom ist und man sich Flügel an die Arme spannt, dass man dann genügend Kraft aus den Armen aufbringen kann, um herum zu fliegen. Also natürlich in der Luft. Im Vakuum geht das natürlich nicht. Aber man müsste wie ein Vogel fliegen können. Das würde ich gerne mal ausprobieren.
Was macht jetzt der Dom anders, als es normalerweise ist?
Naja, was ich damit sagen möchte, ist, du kannst es nicht draußen auf der Mondoberfläche ausprobieren.
Ach so, mit der Mondanziehungskraft. Hätten wir sozusagen dieselbe Luft auf dem Mond, könnte man dort fliegen.
Genau.
Ja, okay. Ja, das wird ja auch den Dinosauriern nachgesagt, dass sie es ein bisschen einfacher hatten, als sie das mit dem Fliegen herausgefunden haben, weil die Erdbeersphäre noch sehr viel dicker war damals. Und man sozusagen auf eine viel schleimigere Luft hatte, auf der man irgendwie herumliegen konnte. Und deswegen war es ihnen sozusagen möglich, da mit ihren ersten Federn auch das Fliegen herauszubilden, was ja dann letzten Endes die Vögel herausgebildet hat. Ah ja, so ein Monddom, da hätte ich dann auch Lust drauf. Das klingt ganz spannend. Ansonsten Parabelschlug kann ich nur empfehlen. Das ist ein ziemlicher Augenöffner, was so Schwerkraft-Relationen betrifft. Okay, also gehen wir mal davon aus, dass das Abbremsen der eigenen Geschwindigkeit bis auf Null, quasi kurz bevor man dann einfach nur noch herunterfällt, aus 6 Metern Abstand, dass das jetzt irgendwie alles geklappt hat. Dann weiß man dann auch schon, wo man ist. Dann fällt das Ding mehr oder weniger nach unten und im Idealfall kippt es nicht gleich über und steht.
Genau. Und dann laden wir halt unsere beiden Rover aus.
Wie viele Füße hat das Ding?
Vier.
Vier Füße, das reicht, ja?
Also, das ist ein guter Industriestandard, sag ich jetzt mal.
Keine Ahnung, so mit Umkippen und so, hätte man ja auch sagen können, ein Bürostell hat ja auch fünf.
Ja, also vier ist irgendwie von der Symmetrie her passt das sehr gut. Also, dann haben wir unsere beiden Rover, die laden wir dann aus. Wie? Das ist ein bisschen schwer verbal zu beschreiben, aber wir haben so Deckklappen, die gehen dann erstmal hoch.
Also, ich meine, bevor das passiert, denke ich mal, wird es ja nochmal ein paar Tests geben, oder? Ich meine, man macht ja jetzt nicht immer alles sofort und schon gar nicht automatisch.
Nee, klar.
Das heißt, wenn das Ding dann erstmal steht, dann hat man aber auch schon quasi, wenn die Kamerabilder eigentlich die ganze Zeit gestreamt?
Also, das bei dem Landeanflug wissen wir das noch nicht genau. Aber während wir dann auf der Oberfläche sind, werden wir da auf jeden Fall die runter übertragen.
Ja, gut. Das hätte ich mir jetzt auch gedacht. Aber während des Landeanflugs, das verbraucht ja auch Energie, keine Ahnung.
Genau, das müssen wir noch im Detail evaluieren. Das hängt davon ab, welche Datenraten wir aufgebaut bekommen über die X-Band-Antennen, welche Leistungen wir da zur Verfügung stellen können.
Also X-Band ist sozusagen das Band, das man verwendet, das schon relativ hohe Übertragungsraten ermöglicht im Vergleich zu der Kommunikation, die noch so vor 20, 30 Jahren angesagt war. Aber in dem Moment, wo man steht, gibt es erstmal einen schönen Blick. Was lösen diese Kameras dann auf?
Also unsere Kameras haben 2048 x 2048 Pixel. Und da haben wir...
Wie viele gibt es?
Auf dem Rover haben wir... Jetzt muss ich kurz überlegen, sieben.
Wenn ich mal auf dem Lender?
Entschuldigung, auf dem Lender.
Achso, auf dem Lender habt ihr sieben.
Auf dem Lender haben wir sieben Kameras. Und der Rover hat vier Kameras. Davon sind drei in dem Kamerakopf. Und ein Fischauge guckt quasi nach unten auf den Boden.
Das heißt, beim Lender sind sieben quasi im Kreis angeordnet?
Vier sind im Kreis angeordnet. Zwei nach unten und eine nach oben.
Zwei nach unten, weil man da ein sehr großes Blickfeld haben möchte für die eigentliche Landung.
Genau, für den Landanflug.
Und oben ist eigentlich langweilig.
Ja, kann auch interessant sein.
Der Blick zurück zur Erde etc. Aber da ist jetzt nicht so der hohe Bedarf für die Auflösung da. Man schaut quasi in jede der vier Richtungen. Man schaut nach unten, versucht es nur gerade vorzustellen. Das heißt, man könnte im Prinzip auch so ein richtiges Panoramabild live streamen. Aber das werdet ihr so wahrscheinlich nicht tun, sondern erstmal empfangen.
Genau, also wichtig ist halt, wir haben halt den permanenten Telemetriestream. Der geht über S-Band, das ist so ein niedrigeres Frequenzband. Das sind auch nicht so viele Daten. Und wenn wir dann auf der Oberfläche sind, haben wir halt eine X-Band-Antenne, die ein bisschen Richtwirkung hat, sodass wir die dann auf die Erde ausrichten. Und dann können wir da mindestens 2 MBit zur Erde übertragen mit den großen Schlüsseln auf der Erde. Und damit würden wir dann natürlich die Bilddaten von dem Landeanflug, die ja wirklich extrem interessant sind, übertragen. Und natürlich die ganzen Aufzeichnungen, die wir von dem Landeanflug gemacht haben. Wir reden natürlich immer wahnsinnig gerne darüber, was wir alles auf der Oberfläche machen. Aber wenn wir da angekommen sind und nicht einen neuen Krater gemacht haben, dann haben wir eigentlich schon 75 Prozent von unserer Mission erfüllt. Die größte Schwierigkeit ist es eigentlich wirklich, da hinzukommen. Und das, was wir auf der Oberfläche dann machen, das ist alles sehr nett. Aber für die Raumfahrt insgesamt ist dieses Landen eigentlich schon das Wichtigste.
Wie kommen die da raus? Also ich meine, das Ding steht, hat wahrscheinlich einen gewissen Abstand mit der Unterseite zum Boden.
Also der Abstand zum Boden ist gar nicht so hoch. Das sind so, ich glaube, 40 Zentimeter, 50 Zentimeter. Und die Rover sind an der Seite senkrecht drinnen. Da ist eine Klappe drüber, die wird dann erstmal weggefahren per Feder. Und dann wird der Rover an den oberen Enden losgemacht und kann dann, klappt dann quasi runter auf die Oberfläche.
Also klappt so seitlich raus sozusagen.
Genau, und dann wird der hinten losgemacht und dann kann er sich frei bewegen. So, und von dort aus fahren wir dann mit dem Rover, natürlich erstmal die 500 Meter, aber dann fahren wir Richtung Apollo 17. Und das ist das, wo es dann wirklich richtig spannend wird.
Warum sind es denn zwei Rover?
Ganz einfach Renundanz. Also es gibt ja eine gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es kaputt geht. Das andere ist aber auch, dass es für uns wichtig ist, wegen der Symmetrie der Beladung von Alina. Das macht es dann einfacher. Also das muss ja im Gleichgewicht sein, das Raumschiff quasi. Es hat auch noch einen netten Nebeneffekt, wenn man mit dem Fahrzeug über den Mond fährt, hat man so ein Disembody Feeling, also dass man halt so körperlos durch die Gegend gleitet. Und wenn man mit dem zweiten Rover, können wir dann halt filmen, wie der erste Rover lang fährt. Das ist ein bisschen...
Können sich gegenseitig beobachten sozusagen.
Genau, das macht für uns das Fahren ein bisschen leichter. Ist aber auch für die Zuschauer irgendwie angenehmer.
Das heißt, der Rover wird auch nicht autonom unterwegs sein, sondern quasi ferngesteuert.
Das ist effektiv in ferngesteuert. Das ist ein Auto mit einer Fahrerassistenz im Mission-Kontrollzentrum. Also wir werden in dem Kontrollzentrum dann für den Fahrer halt so Assistenzsysteme zur Verfügung haben, dass er sagt, hier ist es safe lang zu fahren, da ist es nicht so safe. Und auch Methoden, um mit diesen 3-Sekunden-Signalverzögerungen besser klarzukommen. Also eine Möglichkeit ist zum Beispiel, dass man einen virtuellen Rover fährt und der ist dann quasi 3 Sekunden in der Zukunft und hofft, dass der reale Rover dem dann hinterherkommt.
Ja, also man fährt sozusagen in der Zukunft vor und dann werden die Signale dann halt später ausgeführt. Und in dem Moment, wo dann das Feedback kommt, wie es tatsächlich gelaufen ist, korrigiert sich dann das Ding sozusagen in die Zukunft wieder mit rein.
Der Mensch, der muss dann mit dieser Differenz klarkommen und das dann korrigieren.
Und wie weit seid ihr dann von der Landestelle im Idealfall entfernt?
Also die Fahrdauer, also die Fahrstrecke, die wir dahinten brauchen.
Also ich meine jetzt die Apollo-17-Landestelle.
Das wird so drei bis vier Kilometer sein. Also wir versuchen, wir haben halt eine Landellipse, die ist zwei mal ein Kilometer groß und wir müssen halt mindestens zwei Kilometer Abstand zur Landestelle von Apollo-17 haben. Und das ergibt dann so eine Fahrdistance von fast fünf Kilometern sogar, weil wir ein bisschen zigzag fahren müssen. Warum? Es gibt von NASA gibt es Lunar Heritage Guidelines und da steht zum Beispiel drin, wie man sich der so einer Apollo-Landestelle zu nähern hat. Und eine der Anforderungen ist zum Beispiel, dass man nicht direkt auf die Landestelle zufährt, sondern dass man in einem in einem zigzag dazu rauf fährt, damit falls der Rover aus irgendwelchen Gründen immer seine Operation genau weiter durchführt, dass er dann nicht auf die Landestelle aus Versehen rauf fährt, sozusagen. Genau, und diese Heritage Guidelines geben auch diesen 2 km Abstand bei der Landung vor.
Wir versuchen das hier gerade mal zu vergegenwärtigen. Google Earth hat ja diese schöne Funktion, auch mal den Mond anzeigen zu können, mit den ganzen Routen, die damals gefahren wurden. Wobei jetzt so die, ich fragte ja vorhin nach der Kartografierung, also so hochauflösend sieht das jetzt auf den ersten Blick.
Ja, ich kann dir auch zeigen, wo es die schönen Bilder gibt. In Google Earth wollten sie jetzt mal ein neues Update einspielen mit den neuesten Daten, aber das haben sie noch nicht gemacht. Ja, also der LRO hat halt so eine schöne Kamera und mit denen macht er wirklich sehr tolle Bilder. Und die haben sie dann jetzt mal eingebaut. Also das Problem ist halt, die sind in der derzeitigen Google noch nicht drin, aber ich habe mit dem Techniker gesprochen und der meinte, der wollte die bis Ende des Jahres einfliegen.
LRO ist der Lunar Reconnaissance Orbiter und der ist 2009 dann stattgegangen. Wenn ich jetzt hier mal, also tatsächlich ist die Apollo-17-Landestelle jetzt mal zumindest schon mal höher aufgelöst. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt schon das Maximum ist. Würde ich mal sagen, nein. Das ist ja noch relativ grob, wenn auch deutlich besser als das, alles drumherum. Da sind schon so ein paar nennenswerte Hügel hier. Ich weiß nicht, was für Abstände wir jetzt hier reden, dieses Tal, was man da...
Ja, also das ist schon ziemlich groß. Also wenn wir in einen Hügel da reinfliegen, dann ist was mit unserer Planung aber signifikant schiefgelaufen.
Was ist da der Abstand in etwa? Kann man noch sagen, wie groß dieses Tal hier ist? Weil ich habe hier gerade keine Skala. Vielleicht kann ich ja hier auch was messen. Ja, kann man was messen. Sehr schön, wie modern. Goldene Zeiten, sage ich nur. Jetzt muss er mir nur noch anzeigen, was er jetzt hier gemessen hat. Also, hier von der einen Seite. Okay, ich sag mal so 6 bis 8 Kilometer ungefähr. Und ihr glaubt, dass ihr schon etwas zielgerichtet darauf losfliegen könnt? Also wenn es jetzt top läuft, wie nahe ist man dann sozusagen an Apollo 17 dran?
Also die 3 bis 4 Kilometer, das ist unser Ziel.
Okay, also zu einem gewissen Sicherheitsabstand. Nicht, dass ihr dann irgendwie so mitten...
Nein, nein, also was man bedenken muss, ist, dass zum Beispiel beim Landen wird ja Staub aufgewirbelt. Und dieser Staub sollte auf keinen Fall bis zur Apollo-Landestelle fliegen können, um dann nicht irgendwelche Experimente abzudecken oder irgendwas zu beschädigen. Das ist so eine der Grundideen dahinter.
Was steht denn da noch so rum?
Also da gibt es ALSEP, das ist dieses Experiment-Package quasi. Das sind verschiedene Experimente, die da rumstehen. Und dann steht da vor allem noch der LRV rum, also das Lunar Rover Vehicle, mit dem die Apollo-Astronauten da durch die Gegend gefahren sind. Und das ist auch das, was für uns besonders interessant sein wird. Wir wollen halt mit unseren Kameras untersuchen, was mit diesem Lunar Rover Vehicle da quasi geschehen ist. Also wie sieht er jetzt nach 45 Jahren auf dem Mond aus? Steht er da immer noch genauso, wie er das letzte Mal verlassen wurde? Oder wurde der halt von Mikrometeoriten zu breit zerschossen? Oder hat diese Temperaturschwankungen ihn komplett zersetzt? Oder die Strahlung und so weiter? Also das wird ein unserer Hauptmerkmale der Mission werden, dass wir uns das anschauen im Detail.
Steht der quasi direkt da an der Landestelle?
Ja, das Interessante an der Apollo-17-Mission war, dass sie da halt auch zum ersten Mal tatsächlich einen Geologen mitgesandt haben, und nicht einfach nur so einen Kampfpiloten. Und haben da halt auch wirklich einige geologisch interessante Experimente gemacht. Und Apollo-17 ist auch eine geologisch sehr interessante Zeit. Und deshalb wollen wir da halt auch zurück, weil wir halt einige Experimente damit haben, mit denen wir schauen können, wie da die Materialzusammensetzung ist und ein paar Dinge einfach mal im Detail noch mal genauer anschauen. Eine der Punkte ist, die haben auch die Gravitation sehr im Detail gemessen. Und wir wollen dann quasi zurück zu diesem Punkt und wollen uns dann genau anschauen, ob es da einen Messfehler gab. Also es gibt diese Gravitationsmesswerte. Und wenn man das jetzt modelliert mit dem Tal, dann gibt es an einer Stelle einen Ausreißer. Und wir wollen dann mit unserem Experiment nachschauen, ob an dieser Stelle das jetzt ein Messfehler war oder ob in dem Untergrund da irgendwas geologisch Interessantes ist.
Das heißt, wenn sich da keine besondere Ausbildung herausstellt, dann war es vielleicht eher ein Messfehler. Und wenn man aber so etwas Vergleichbares wieder misst, dann ist da unter Umständen etwas strange.
Und wir können das dann noch ein bisschen detaillierter machen. Damals hatten die auch nicht so die Zeit, das nochmal detaillierter nachzumessen. Ja, die sind auf der Rückseite, oder?
Ja, habe ich auch gehört. Aber vielleicht stimmt das ja alles gar nicht. Das ist ja geil, was die uns erzählen wollen.
Ja, das ist natürlich auch ein netter Nebenaspekt, dass wir dann natürlich dann mal zeigen, dass die NASA da oben auf dem Mond war. Was uns dann natürlich trotzdem keiner glauben wird.
Nein, nein, ihr seid ja auch alle nur fake. Das kann ja gar nicht sein. Nur weil man da jetzt HD-Kameras sieht. Was beweist denn das schon? Ja, nee, das muss man sich auch mal klar machen, dass jetzt wirklich an der Stelle quasi schon lange keiner mehr war. Nicht auf dem Mond an sich, weil da waren ja die Chinesen im letzten Jahr, vorletztes Jahr, zwei Jahre her, glaube ich, jetzt schon mit ihrer Mission, die zumindest so ein bisschen funktioniert hat. Der Rover hat jetzt nicht so mega lange durchgehalten, ich glaube so zwei, drei Tage und dann war vorbei.
250 Meter haben sie wohl zurückgelegt. Also das ist natürlich, das muss man halt auch immer bedenken. Also wenn man sich halt mal das anschaut, es ist einfach eine verdammt große Herausforderung, der wir uns erstellen, an der Agenturen auch scheitern teilweise oder nicht so erfolgreich sind, wie sie es gerne möchten.
Die Chinesen dürften ja auch eine ganze Menge Aufwand getrieben haben.
Gehe ich mal stark von aus, ja.
Beobachtet man das dann auch sehr intensiv, solche Fälle? Also ich habe da überhaupt an Daten ran?
Das war sehr interessant. Also ich hatte auf der Lunar Planetary Science Konferenz, da waren dann tatsächlich zwei Chinesen, die dir da ein Paper präsentiert haben von den Daten, die sie aufgezeichnet haben. Und dann habe ich mal so nachgefragt, was war denn da eigentlich los? Und dann hatte der eine Chinesen, der andere Chinesen gefragt, dürfen wir darüber reden? Und dann haben sie auf Chinesisch gewechselt, und dann haben sie irgendwie hin und her geredet. Und dann haben sie gesagt, der Motor war kaputt. Und dann so, hm, okay, das war jetzt nicht die Detailinformation, die ich gerne gehabt hätte. Also die haben aber jetzt die Daten, die Bilder, die sie gemacht haben, sind online tatsächlich jetzt zugänglich. Also auch da gibt es interessante Bilder, die sie gemacht haben. Und der Mond sieht genauso aus, wie auf den Apollo-Bildern. Also die scheinen das gleiche Studio zu benutzen.
Aber quasi seit der Landung der Chinesen? War da niemand, nee. Wir reden wirklich von der Zeitspanne. Apollo 17, wann sind die gelandet?
1969 glaube ich.
1969 bis vor zwei Jahren 2014.
Ach Quatsch, Moment. 1972 war Apollo 17. 1969 waren die ersten.
Okay.
Also das ist genau 45 Jahre nächstes Jahr im Dezember.
Aber 40 Jahre hat sich da sozusagen nichts getan. Und man würde aber erwarten, dass sich da eben auch nicht so viel verändert hat. Weil da gibt es keinen Wind, da gibt es keine Atmosphäre. Da ist halt alles extrem statisch. Man müsste im Prinzip alle Fußabdrücke noch sehen können.
Also das ist zum Beispiel eine der wirklich spannenden Fragen. Also es ist zum Beispiel so, dass es Theorien gibt. Also der Mond ist positiv geladen und im Dunkeln ist er negativ geladen. Und bei dem Terminator, also da wo der übergang von hell nach dunkel findet so ein Ladungswechsel statt, der dafür sorgt, dass das Teilchen, also feine Regulierteilchen, schweben. Und das heißt, es könnte sein, dass diese Art dafür gesorgt hat, dass das alles mit Staub bedeckt ist. Aber so genau weiß man das alles nicht. Und wenn man dann jetzt mal überlegt, wir wollen da in ein paar Jahren einen Moon Village bauen, dann ist es extrem interessant, mal zurückzugehen und zu schauen...
Wie ist denn da der Niederschlag eigentlich?
Genau. Was ist eigentlich mit diesen Materialien, die vor 45 Jahren auf der Mondüberfläche abgelegt wurden, was ist aus denen geschehen? Hat sich dieses Nylon oder das Leder, was sie damals benutzt haben, hat sich das komplett aufgelöst? Sieht das immer noch genauso aus und so weiter. Und ich glaube, das wird wirklich eine der interessantesten Erkenntnisse von unserer Mission werden.
Fragt man sich ja, warum die Chinesen nicht schon bei Apollo runtergegangen sind.
Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich glaube, die haben das nach der Einfachheit des Landemanövers ausgewählt, dass sie sagten, wir landen einfach irgendwo in der Mitte. Oder vielleicht auch politische Hintergründe. Also wenn dann Chinesen da näher von so einem Apollo landen, dann weiß man ja nicht, was die da vorhaben.
Oder was das mit der USA für Panik auslöst. Aber ihr seid jetzt nicht im Verdacht. Ihr habt ja auch einen Amerikaner im Team, wenn ich das richtig sehe, der da schon so ein wenig involviert war.
Genau, also Jack Cranshaw ist einer der alten Hasen der Flugbahnberechnung. Es gibt ja so eine berühmte Trajektorie, diese Acht, wo man halt zum Mond hinfliegt und wenn man nichts macht, dann kommt man wieder zur Erde zurück. Die hat er zum Beispiel mitentwickelt damals für die Apollo-Mission. Der ist auch ein bisschen älter. Und wenn wir sagen, dass wir nicht alle Vollzeit sind, dann ist bei solchen Leuten auch klar, warum man die nicht vollzeit anstellen kann.
Wie alt ist der jetzt?
Ich glaube, der ist 82.
Aber der hat sich quasi gesagt, ich habe irgendwo auf einer Webseite gelesen, was soll man denn machen in so einem Alter, wenn man sonst nichts zu tun hat? Ich mache halt das, was ich eh kann, und helfe dann dem anderen Team auch noch mal dabei zu landen. Der hat sich sozusagen nur aus Laune dem Projekt angeschlossen.
Genau, er hat einfach Spaß dabei, das noch zu machen. Er hat das Know-how, das ist für uns extrem hilfreich.
Arbeitet er aus den USA?
Nein, er arbeitet aus den USA.
Aber er war schon mal da?
Nein, tatsächlich noch nicht.
Das ist wirklich ein verteiltes Projekt. Habt ihr noch andere Fernarbeiter, die sozusagen so eng mit euch zusammenarbeiten?
Naja, einer unserer Hauptmitglieder lebt in Frankreich. Wir haben viele Österreicher, die in Salzburg und Wien wohnen teilweise. Wo es dann auch ein bisschen schwierig wird für uns, dass wir nicht immer alle vor Ort haben. Das hat dann immer dazu geführt, dass in unserem alten Büro, wo wir dann nur 150 Quadratmeter hatten, dass man dann halt, das war entweder genöde Lehre oder völlige Überfüllung, wenn dann mal alle da waren tatsächlich. Das haben wir jetzt ja nicht geändert.
Okay, kommen wir nochmal zu den Rover. Also wir sind jetzt hier mit den Rover-Staaten, sind ausgeklappt und sollen jetzt das Terrain erkunden. Die haben jetzt auch nochmal Kameras, was hast du gesagt? Vier Stück. Drei am Kopf, die quasi einen Rundumblick erzeugen und einer guckt nach unten, weil immer gut zu wissen, was unten ist. Wo fährt man dann erstmal hin? Also geht es dann sozusagen gleich zur Apollo-17-Landestelle?
Also ich wüsste jetzt nicht, warum wir im Kreis fahren sollten, außer um vielleicht ein paar Ringe in den Mond zu malen. Also es ist so, dass wir vom Prinzip her eigentlich erstmal müssen wir überhaupt wissen, wo wir sind. Das ist nicht so ganz trivial, weil es gibt ja kein GPS da oben. Also wir müssen erstmal genau herausfinden, wo wir wirklich genau gelandet sind. Und dann machen wir uns aber vom Prinzip her auch schon relativ schnell auf den Weg Richtung Apollo 17.
Aber ist das so schwierig? Ich meine, wenn der Länder steht und er guckt irgendwie mit hochaufwürsenden Kameras in alle Richtungen, dann sieht er ja im Prinzip diese ganzen Erhebungen links und rechts. Da müsste man sich doch auch ziemlich leicht positionieren können, oder schätze ich da gerade irgendwas?
Ja, das Problem ist, man wird die Landestelle nicht direkt sehen, sondern die ist so ein bisschen hinter dem Horizont.
Also die Landestelle, die Apollo-17-Landestelle?
Genau, also man könnte sich einfach sagen, ach, da müssen wir lang, okay.
Ach so gut, aber man muss...
Grobe Richtung, ja. Ist aber trotzdem dann auch dann immer noch immer relativ schwierig. Also man sieht dann, okay, hier ist das Tal, also wir müssen in die Richtung losfahren. Aber dann fängt das halt an mit den Details, ja, hinter welcher Kurve müssen wir jetzt ein bisschen links und wo lang. Und dann die Fahrtplanung im Detail machen, dass man halt auch diese Regularien einhält, dass man nicht genau senkrecht auf die Apollo-Landestelle zufährt und so weiter, dass man immer mit dem Zickzack fährt. Das muss man ja auch alles bedenken. Das ist auch nicht so ganz trivial.
Also das Zickzack war sozusagen nur eine Vorsichtsmaßnahme, dass man nicht irgendwie in irgendwas reinfährt, wo man eigentlich hin will.
Genau.
Und der Zickzack ist ein relativ starker Zickzack. Also man fährt erstmal weit nach rechts und dann wieder...
Also die Grundanforderung ist, dass wir halt nicht gerade auf die Landestelle zugucken dürfen beim Fahren. Also das kann man natürlich mit verschiedenen steilen Zickzack-Manövern erreichen, aber wir müssen natürlich auch noch berücksichtigen, was für ein Terrain wir haben. Also man kann ja nicht einfach wirklich gerade drehen, sondern man muss ja den kleinen Kratern da dann auch ausweichen und sowas. Also das wird schon spannend werden.
Also mit 3 Sekunden Verzögerung guckt man dann quasi diese beiden Teile, die dann auch parallel fahren. Also die fahren dann sozusagen im Gänse-Marsch, einer dem anderen hinterher?
So ungefähr, genau, ja.
Und man steuert dann quasi mit einem beide?
Nee, es gibt dann schon zwei Fahrerteams, die unabhängig voneinander die Rover steuern. Ja, also ich bin da auch schon sehr gespannt darauf.
Jetzt haben wir viel über Landen und Ankommen und so weiter geredet und wie schön es doch ist, mit Rovern auf fremden Scheinshörpern durch die Gegend zu fahren. Weil wir ja am Ende dann auch so ein bisschen wissenschaftlich auch Niederschlag haben. Was sind denn so für Experimente und Sensoren auf den drei Geräten, von denen wir jetzt hier im Prinzip sprechen, installiert? Und was für Messungen sollen jetzt über diese Gravitationsmessungen, die du schon angedeutet hast, hinaus durchgeführt werden?
Also wir haben zum einen bei unseren Kameras, da ist ein schwarz-weiß-Sensor mit einem Filterrad davor. Da können wir uns dann verschiedene Wellenlängen anschauen. Das heißt, man kann dann so eine grundlegende Materialzusammensetzung von dem Boden oder von dem Rover machen. Dann arbeiten wir an einem Experiment, was noch nicht ganz entschieden ist, ob wir es schaffen, mitzufliegen in der ersten Mission. Da geht es darum, dass man mit einem Laser den Boden aufschmilzt, dass man einen ganz einfachen 3D-Druck demonstriert. Auf dem Länder haben wir dann noch unser Lunar Plant-Cross-Experiment. Da geht es darum, dass man eine Pflanze in dieser Mondumgebung züchtet, um zu schauen, wie die dort wächst. Man weiß ja, auf der Erde funktioniert das mit dem Pflanzenwachstum ganz gut. Auf der ISS geraten die Pflanzen ein bisschen durcheinander, weil sie vermutlich die Gravitation brauchen, um zu wissen, in welche Richtung sie mit den Wurzeln gehen sollen. Und die Frage ist, was passiert dann zum Beispiel bei einer Sechsel Schwerkraft mit der Strahlung, Umgebung und so weiter, die man da hat. Würden die dann dort auch genauso wachsen oder nicht? Was für Pflanzen? Das entscheiden unsere Wissenschaftler. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau. Das sind so kleine Pflanzen, die immer für diese Samenwachsgeschichten benutzt werden.
Ja, ein wertes, vergleichbares Material. Ich habe auch mal einen Namen gehört, habe ich jetzt gerade auch nicht parat. Aber da gibt es sozusagen so die, die man immer nimmt.
Genau, die Fruchtfliege der Pflanzenwachsung.
Das war schon. Das heißt, ihr tragt da quasi einen Samen hin? Oder ist da schon so ein Stickling an Bord?
Also das ist ein eigenes Biotop. Es macht keinen Sinn, einen Samenkorn in den Regulitboden, in den Vakuum zu packen. Das weiß man, das wird ja sofort nicht funktionieren. Sondern man hat da so ein kleines, abgeschlossenes Biotop mit einer eigenen Beleuchtung, eigenem Sauerstoff, eigenem Wasser und so weiter.
Die Pflanze hat sich sozusagen schon ein Stück weit entwickelt, wenn sie auf die Reise geht?
Nein, das ist ein Samen.
Also es wird dann tatsächlich vor Ort gepflanzt und komplett geguckt?
Genau.
Okay, das heißt, es muss auch eine Pflanze sein, die halt schnell wächst. Das kann man sozusagen in der kurzen Zeit das auch wirklich beobachten.
Genau, also die hat, glaube ich, irgendwie sieben Tage Wachstum und dann stirbt sie auch schon. Also, weil der Sauerstoff ausgeht. Also, dann haben wir noch ein paar...
Also, bleiben wir erstmal bei Alina, unabhängig von den Rohrwanden. Also, bei Alina ist...
Das Lunar Plant Cross-Experiment drauf. Dann haben wir ein Experiment von schwedischen Wissenschaftlern. Da geht es darum, das elektrostatische Feld zu messen. Vor allem den Wechsel davon, wenn dann die Nacht quasi ankommt. Und das ist halt wirklich interessant, um zu schauen, ob diese elektrostatischen Effekte, die man da vorher gesagt hat, ob die tatsächlich irgendwie so eintreten und wie dieser Feldwechsel dann im Detail stattfindet.
Also das, was diesen Slow-Mo-Sandsturm quasi auslösen könnte vielleicht.
Genau, genau. Und dann haben wir noch ein paar Nutzlasten auf Alina, die halt kommerziell sind, die wir jetzt aber nicht ankündigen können. Die wollen noch warten, bis sie das bekannt geben.
Und auf dem Rover?
Ja, auf dem Rover gibt es halt zum einen das Laser-Sinter-Experiment, mit dem wir versuchen, den Mondboden aufzuschmelzen, um 3D-Druck zu demonstrieren. Und das Gravimeter, mit dem man die Gravitation extrem genau messen kann. Und natürlich unsere Kamera, mit der wir die Bilder aufsammeln.
Und die Kamera, ist das jetzt so eine normale Kamera, die nur unsere normalen sichtbaren Wellen aufnimmt, oder werden da auch noch andere Lichtwellen aufgenommen?
Also der Sensor, den wir dort haben, der ist im Infrarotbereich schon noch ein bisschen empfindlicher, als die Standard-Industrie-Sensoren, also die Standard-Sensoren, die sonst so benutzt werden. Aber ansonsten ist das eigentlich ein relativ normaler Chip. Aber es ist alles eine eigene Entwicklung von uns. Also wir haben wirklich sehr viel Elektronik für unsere Mission selber entwickelt.
Einschließlich der Kameras. Puh, als ob jetzt so Rover noch nicht reichen würde sozusagen. Aber das ist sozusagen in diesem Glauben, was wir am Anfang schon besprochen haben, Herrscher der Plattform sein, sozusagen selber. Und auch wenn es dann halt mal nicht funktioniert, zumindest zu wissen, wo man dann das nächste Mal ansetzen sollte, um es irgendwie zum Funktionieren zu bringen. Aber das ist ja gerade in der Softwareentwicklung einfach extrem wichtig, dass man einfach weiß, auf welche Komponenten man zurückgreift. Und nicht, dass man dann irgendwie auf dem Mond rumsteht und feststellt, dass man jetzt ein Software-Update haben will, bevor es weiterfährt.
Genau, also das Problem ist ja zum Beispiel, der Chef von diesem Lunar Planet Cross-Experiment meinte dann so, warum könnt ihr denn die USB-Kamera, die wir da einbauen wollen, nicht einfach direkt bei euch an den Boardcomputer anschließen? Und ich so, ne, der hat einfach noch nicht versucht, einen Treiber unter Windows mal irgendwie ans Laufen zu bekommen von so einer USB-Kamera scheinbar. Also das können wir auf unserer Mission einfach nicht leisten.
Ja, da ist ja auch, sagen wir mal, auch unnötige Komplexität an der Stelle. Dieses Sinter-Experiment, das ist natürlich jetzt wirklich krass. Also wenn ich das richtig verstehe, also Sinter-3D-Drucker, das ist ja nichts Neues, das gibt es ja schon im industriellen Bereich schon lange. Üblicherweise kennt man ja immer so die Dinger, die mit den Plastikwürsten arbeiten, weil das natürlich viel, viel, viel günstiger ist, oder zumindest bisher war. Aber es gab schon immer diese Systeme, das habe ich, glaube ich, schon vor 20 Jahren gesehen, die so mit Laser in so eine Art Sand reinstrahlen und mit der Punkthitze an der Stelle dieses Material quasi miteinander verschmelzen und da hochrobuste, auch sehr hochaufgelöste Prototypen erzeugen kann. Wobei nicht nur Prototypen, ich glaube mittlerweile ist das auch schon so quasi so produktionsreif, aber man sieht diese Laser-Dinger eigentlich relativ selten. Die sind ziemlich teuer, ja.
Also an unserem Rover sind ja sehr viele Aluteile tatsächlich aus 3D-Druck gefertigt, die dieses Laser-Sintering benutzen von Aluminium. Dadurch kann man wirklich extrem dünnwannige Strukturen machen, die dann halt auch sehr leicht sind und trotzdem sehr stabil sind. Ja, effektiv schon, ja. Und bei uns geht es halt darum, dass wir wirklich einfach zeigen wollen, dass dieses Material, was auf das Deckmaterial, dass das dazu geeignet ist, um wirklich 3D-Druck auf dem Mond mit dem Mondstaub zu machen. Und das geht halt wirklich in die Zukunftsrichtung, dass wir den Grundstein legen wollen für das Moon Village, wie Werner sich das quasi so vorstellt. Genau. Und das haben sie ja leider nicht jetzt beschlossen quasi, aber sie haben es ja bei der Ministerratskonferenz wenigstens mal erwähnt gehabt, dass das ein schönes Projekt ist.
Hattet ihr denn schon eure Hand mal an Regolith? Also könntet ihr mit Original-Mondstaub-Tests fahren?
Also es gibt natürlich diese Simulanten, mit denen wir das machen. Die sind auch sehr gut erforscht. Und es gibt auch einen, mit dem wir im Kontakt waren, der das probiert hat, mit Originalstaub, den er tatsächlich von der Nase bekommen hat. Und er meinte, es gibt da keine signifikanten Unterschiede zwischen dem Simulant und dem tatsächlichen Regolith. Aber es ist halt ein Experiment.
Ich meine, der Mond ist ja letztlich auch aus der Rippe der Erde geboren. Das ist jetzt keine komplett andere Welt, auch wenn sie so ein bisschen rüberkommt. Und was druckt ihr dann da?
Das wird jetzt kein...
Dann lasst ihr da so Part-Time-Scientists-Logos irgendwie.
Darüber machen wir uns dann Gedanken, wenn das dann tatsächlich funktionieren sollte. Also es geht jetzt eigentlich erstmal darum, das Grundprinzip einfach nur mal zu demonstrieren. Also wirklich zu zeigen, dass dieser Boden aufgeschmolzen werden kann, dass das, was da rauskommt, eine gewisse Festigkeit hat und man das dann für spätere 3D-Druckaktionen benutzen könnte.
Und ist dieses System im Rover eingebaut, in beiden?
Nee, in einem. Also wir haben in dem einen das Gravimeter zum Beispiel und in dem anderen das 3D-Druck-Experiment.
Haben die einen Namen?
Momentan heißen die noch Audi, Luna, Quattro, aber...
Ich meine, die müssen ja irgendwie unteratschieden werden.
Nee, da arbeiten wir noch dran.
Klassisches Problem der Informatik. Wie benennt man zwei Systeme? Kommt dann immer so Castor und Pollux, aber das ist irgendwie auch schon durch. Gut, dann machen wir mal A und B. Das heißt, sie sind im Prinzip ähnlich, aber sie haben tatsächlich komplett andere Instrumente an Bord. Und wenn jetzt dieser Regulit mit dem Laser bestrahlt wird und da entsteht halt irgendwie so ein Geschmelze, dann muss man das ja dann sozusagen auch noch untersuchen. Also ist da dann sozusagen noch ein Greifarm, der das dann irgendwie nimmt oder wird eine Regulitprobe in den Rover reingezogen? Also wo findet das statt?
Also das ist tatsächlich eine der ganz großen Schwierigkeiten, dass wir halt keinen Manipulator haben, mit dem man irgendwas Sinnvolles machen kann. Das heißt, der Test wird dann relativ einfach sein, dass wir mit dem Rad rüberfahren und gucken, bricht das, was passiert damit. Wird sehr basic sein. Es geht eher darum, zu zeigen, dass es möglich ist, dass wir dieses aufschmelzen und zu gucken, wie sieht das Ergebnis aus. Das ist auch eine optische Inspektion. Vielleicht mit unserer Multispektralkamera nochmal das im Detail anschauen. Und dann versuchen wir aus der optischen Auswertung Daten herauszuziehen.
Das heißt, der Laser kommt einfach nur aus dem Rover raus und schießt vorne quasi in den Sand?
Der kommt unten raus und hat tatsächlich so eine Scan-Einheit, dass wir dann da Muster machen können. Also, I was here würde tatsächlich eventuell gehen.
Und das kann man dann so zahlmal auch dynamisch noch poamieren. Also, wenn man merkt, dass es gut funktioniert, dann...
Also, unser Partner, mit dem wir das zusammen machen, das wäre ganz schwierig, aber ich glaube, wir reden noch von ihm, dass wir da neue Muster hochladen können.
Sicher Sponsoring Opportunities.
Ja, das bereiten wir uns tatsächlich vor.
Ja, die Meta eben, die hat ein ganz einfaches Logo. So, und wenn die dann auf die Landestelle getroffen sind, die Rover, gibt es da noch was zu untersuchen, oder ist es im Wesentlichen wirklich die Gravitationsmessung und die Lasermessung?
Also, wenn wir dann bei der Landestelle angekommen sind, dann gucken wir uns natürlich den Zustand des LFVs an, also des Mondfahrzeuges, um halt dort wirklich mit unserer hochaufgelösten Kamera Detailfotos davon zu machen, wie diese Materialien sich nach 45 Jahren auf der Oberfläche geschlagen haben. Also, ob das jetzt irgendwie total aufgelöst wurde, oder ob das alles zerbrochen ist, was die Strahlung damit gemacht hat, ob das ausgebleicht ist und solche Geschichten. Und wenn wir dann damit durch sind, dann werden wir weiterfahren zu einem dieser Messpunkte, wo diese Anämonie aufgetreten ist und werden das nochmal nachmessen. Und wenn wir dann immer noch Zeit haben und unser Rover immer noch funktioniert, dann wird es spannend. Dann wissen wir noch nicht genau, was wir damit machen. Aber Baby steps first. Also, wenn wir da oben ankommen, landen und die Rover ausladen und die ein bisschen herumfahren können, dann haben wir schon, glaube ich, so viel erreicht, das reicht dann auch irgendwann.
Mehr geht ja immer, ne? Also, ich halte das auch für den richtigen Ansatz, sich da deck zu halten. Aber die Zeit ist ja auch limitiert. Also, wenn man es nochmal schaut, wir haben im Prinzip ja ein maximales Zeitfenster von...
Elfeinhalb Tagen, genau.
Elfeinhalb Tagen. Und danach ist was dann nicht mehr okay?
Also, die elfenhalb Tage kommen wir daher, dass wir ein paar Tage verlieren, weil wir auf den richtigen Sonnenstand warten müssen. Und dann, nach elfenhalb Tagen, setzt dann die Dunkelheit ein. Und da wir halt mit Solar betrieben sind und Batterie zum Puffer haben, ist es dann effektiv auch vorbei mit dem Herumfahren. Und die Temperatur geht dann so schnell, so steil runter, dass wir davon ausgehen, dass der Rover danach kaputt ist. Vermutlich die Elektronik. Also das Problem ist einfach dieser schnelle Temperaturwechsel von 120 Grad Celsius auf, nicht 120 Grad, aber von einer relativ hohen Temperatur auf eine sehr niedrige Temperatur. Kann halt dazu führen, dass halt von diesen Beinchen, dass dann Lötstellen brechen von den BGRs, die die Balls irgendwie kaputt gehen oder die Leiterbahnen reißen. Solche Geschichten.
Aber ist die Elektronik schon in irgendeiner Form für Sonderbelastungen präpariert?
Na klar, also wir machen natürlich mit denen die ganzen Batterie-Antests, also Vibrationen und Thermalzyklen-Tests, aber halt nicht in diesem Extremtemperaturbereich, sondern in einem abgespeckten Bereich, den wir für den Flug und für den Oberflächeneinsatz garantieren können.
Aber es könnte ja auch sein, dass er das irgendwie überlebt.
Genau, also wir werden auf jeden Fall am ersten Sonnenlicht dann nochmal reinhorchen, ob da sich jemand meldet.
Also das Ding ist auf jeden Fall so programmiert, dass wenn es mal aus war und dann wieder Strom hat, dass es sich dann automatisch bootet.
Genau, und dann schauen wir mal. Wenn es dann was empfängt und noch reagiert, dann ist das schon ziemlich gut. Wenn es dann noch herumfährt, dann müssen wir uns tatsächlich einen besseren Plan darüber machen, was wir dann noch damit machen wollen. Aber herumfahren und Bilder machen kann man ja immer noch. Man kann zum Beispiel vom Taurus-Lito-Tal weiter nach Westen rausfahren. Und dort gibt es dann zum Beispiel solche eingefallenen Lava-Tubes, oder zumindest etwas, was so ähnlich aussieht wie so ein eingefallener Lava-Tube. Und dann kann man sich das dann nochmal im Detail anschauen. Da hat man dann erst mal ein paar 20 Kilometer oder noch mehr unterwegs.
Wie schnell ist denn der Rover?
Der ist der langsamste Audi, der je gebaut wurde mit 3,6 kmh Top-Geschwindigkeit. Wobei wir die aber wahrscheinlich so noch nicht mal ausfahren können.
Weil man immer wieder mal stoppen muss sozusagen.
Wegen der Zeitverzögerung ist das nicht so ganz einfach tatsächlich.
Okay, das ist ja immerhin schon so Schrittgeschwindigkeit, wie man sich so normalerweise auf dem Bürgersteig bewegt. Das finde ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt schon ziemlich schnell.
Ja, es ist nicht so richtig langsam, aber es ist halt, wenn man dann mal eine größere Distanz zurücklegen möchte, dann doch irgendwie nervig.
Aber dieser LRV von dem Apollo-Projekt, der war ja ganz schön, der war ganz gut unterwegs.
Genau, Dean Cernan hat uns auch noch mal verwarnt, dass wir auf gar keinen Fall seinen Geschwindigkeitsreport brechen dürfen. Ich glaube, mit 18 kmh ist er da irgendwo den Berg runter gejuckelt. Da sind wir aber auch weit von entfernt. Ja, also ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass die da auch ziemlich Spaß hatten. Das hat er mir auch noch mal bestätigt.
3,6 kmh, das heißt im Prinzip, wenn jetzt sozusagen 10 Tage effektive Nutzzeit dabei abfallen, so netto, könnte man eigentlich durchgehend 24 Stunden darum fahren. Weil es ist ja eigentlich die ganze Zeit Licht. Wie macht ihr denn das dann quasi mit der Betreuung? Weil dann will man ja auch keine Minute verlieren. Und das wird ja jetzt nicht 10 Tage lang, 24 Stunden lang wach sein. Das heißt, es gibt dann so ein Team aus mehreren Leuten, die immer wieder Handover machen?
Ja, genau, also wir haben dann so einen Mehrschichtbetrieb, mit dem wir dann versuchen wirklich 24-7 das durchzuziehen. Das wird nicht immer ganz klappen, weil die Satellitenschüssel natürlich auch begehrt sind für andere Deep Space-Missionen und wir dann teilweise mal vermutlich keine Kommunikation herstellen können für den Zeitraum. Aber vom Prinzip her ist es angedacht, dass wir die Zeit, die wir dort oben haben, auch wirklich dann voll nutzen.
Wie exklusiv nutzt man denn dann diese Deep Space S-Track-Technologie? Die können ja schon auch mehr als ein Signal gleichzeitig empfangen.
Ja genau, also wir benutzen eine Schüssel, um alle Signale von Alina, von den beiden Rover gleichzeitig zu empfangen. Aber diese eine Schüssel benutzen wir dann halt auch vollständig. Und das sind halt die dicken Schüsseln, die 30-Meter-Schüsseln.
Exklusiv? Und wie viele Stunden pro Tag könnt ihr dann die haben? Ist das eine Geldfrage oder ist das eine Reservierungsfrage? Prioritätenfrage?
Es ist in gewisser Weise eine scheduling Frage. Also theoretisch, das ist das, was wir jetzt gerade erarbeiten, dass wir, wir hätten sie gerne 24-7, wirklich für die 10 Tage.
Aber das heißt ja, dass keine Deep Space Mission, der ESA und so weiter...
Nee, so funktioniert das nicht. Also die haben ja, wir haben immer pro Schüssel immer 8 Stunden Maximum, wo wir den Mond ja überhaupt sehen.
Das heißt, man wechselt auf jeden Fall schon mal die Station. Über 24 Stunden schon mal dreimal die Station.
Genau. Und zwischen den Stationen wechseln wir dann halt dann immer durch.
Also problematisch ist es sozusagen nur, wenn die eine von den drei Schlüsseln, die man jetzt gerade haben möchte, nutzen möchte, wenn die auch im Schedule ist, um jetzt irgendeinen Deep Space Mission Kontakt vorzunehmen. Weil es gibt ja noch so einiges, was da draußen rumfliegt. Die Kometen-Mission ist jetzt beendet, aber Cassini ist ja noch am Kral, ich weiß gar nicht, benutzen die auch dieselbe Infrastruktur, die NASA-Mission?
Also die NASA hat ja das Deep Space Network. Die haben ja quasi noch mal ihr eigenes Set an Schlüsseln. Aber wobei es da halt wirklich auch eine Kooperation zwischen der NASA und der ESA gibt, dass die sich dann teilweise aushelfen. Oder dass man halt auch schaut, ist das jetzt einfach nur unser tägliches Telemetrie-Dump, der einfach irgendwie sagt immer, hallo ich bin da und die ist gerade in einer sehr unkritischen Phase, dann kann man sagen, ok, können wir jetzt auch mal darauf verzichten. Also da gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten, wie man diesen Schedule realisieren kann.
Das heißt, von diesen acht Stunden könnte man sogar einen Großteil bekommen.
Das sieht sehr gut aus.
Kostgeld.
Ja, das Geld ist auch gar nicht mal so viel. Das sind nur ein paar hunderttausend. Man verliert ein bisschen die Perspektiven, wenn man zu lange in dieser Branche ist.
Ja gut, das ist ja nun auch die Essenz. Ich meine, jetzt hat man diesen ganzen Aufwand getrieben, dann sagt man, ja, jetzt auf den Mond rumfahren und so weiter. Nächste Woche machen. Das geht halt nicht. Man hat eigentlich nur die Zeit und dann will man sie auch total nutzen. So und wenn in dem Fall, also man nutzt dann sozusagen Schüsseln, die sowohl S-Band als auch X-Band gleichzeitig können. Also man hat sowohl den Command- und Kontrollbereich als auch die reinen Nutzdaten, also in dem Fall halt das Video-Streaming. Und wenn das nur zwei Megabit sind, die da quasi rauskommen können und man fährt aber jetzt mit zwei Rovern, mit, was war das, 4 x 2k Bildern rum, da sind ja schon eine ganze Menge Daten. Also das ist ja jetzt sozusagen nicht, das ist ja kein Pappenstil. So zwei Megabit, das würde man so im Internet-Streaming vielleicht für Full-HD-Übertragung mal so benutzen und schon ein ganz ordentliches Bild rausbekommen. Aber damit hat man ja noch nicht gleich acht Kameras im Vollbetrieb.
Nee, also es ist tatsächlich so, dass die Rover, also jeder Rover und der Länder haben einen eigenen Frequenzband. Das heißt, wir können quasi 3 x 2 Mbit gleichzeitig zur Erde übertragen. Und bei dem Rover ist es so, dass wir halt immer zwei Kameras aktiv haben. Und dann gibt es halt alle paar Sekunden noch mal dann vielleicht von dem... Wir haben jetzt schon mal ein Bild von der Kamera unten. Aber zum Beispiel die Telekamera brauchen wir nicht zum Fahren. Die ist halt dann für Detailanalysen sinnvoll.
Was sind die Telekameras nach unten?
Die Telekamera ist unsere Multispektralkamera. Die benutzt man halt für Panoramen, für hochaufgelöste Panoramen oder wenn man sich mal einen Stein genau anschauen möchte. Und die Hazardcam, die nach unten schaut, die wird man jetzt auch nicht immer mit einer vollen Aktualisierungsrate benötigen.
Das heißt, für die vier Kameras sind zwei quasi im Wesentlichen für den Dauerbetrieb. Das heißt, die schauen so quasi stereomäßig nach vorne. Genau. Die Multispektralkamera, die guckt dann in die andere Richtung oder?
Also die ist ja in dem gleichen Kamerakopf drin. Die guckt dann auch in die gleiche Richtung, aber die wird halt dann nur bei zu besonderen Anlässen.
Ja, für wissenschaftliche Untersuchungen, nicht so sehr für das Fahren. Und die Hazardcam, also die schaut sozusagen nur, ist da jetzt gerade irgendwie ein Stein, der uns gefährlich werden könnte oder sollte sich halt irgendwie was auf dem Boden befinden, was man sich jetzt mal ganz genau anschauen will.
Also die Hazardcam, dafür würde man sogar auch die Telekamera benutzen. Also die Hazardcam ist eigentlich wirklich eher für den Fall, man ist jetzt stecken geblieben und möchte herausfinden, wie können wir uns aus dieser Misere befreien. Weil da sieht man zum Beispiel alle vier Räder, man kann dann schauen, ist dieses Rad blockiert oder was ist mit dem Rad, dreht sich das überhaupt und so weiter. Weil das sieht man mit den Kameras oben auf dem Kamerakopf, sieht man die Räder so nicht.
Und der Kamerakopf kann sich im Prinzip in jede Richtung bewegen, also man kann damit sozusagen herum und auch so 360 Grad herum schauen.
Also genau, der kann sich 360 Grad drehen und 60 Grad nach oben, glaube ich, und auch 60 Grad nach unten, wenn das Richtige ist.
Das heißt, da kann man schöne Panoramabilder machen, der stellt sich irgendwo hin und dann fährt er mal alles ab, nach oben und nach unten geneigt. Also man hat nicht wirklich jetzt einen kompletten Dom, keine komplette Kugel, aber einen relativ großen Winkel, der so für eine normale Rundumbetrachtung schon mal ganz gut herhält.
Genau, also was wir machen können, ist ein Gigapixel-Panorama. Und dadurch, dass wir nicht das Bayer-Pattern haben, sondern wir halt einen Schwarz-Weiß-Sensor haben, wo dann der rot und der grüne und der blaue Kanal nacheinander... Also wenn man jetzt so eine Farbkamera hat, dann gibt es da immer ein grünes Pixel, dann ein rotes, und in der nächsten Zeile ist dann noch mal ein grünes und noch mal ein blaues Pixel. Und aus diesen vier Pixeln werden dann vier Farbpixeln berechnet. Und das ist halt, wenn man jetzt ein hochdedeiertes Panorama machen möchte, dann sind diese vier Pixel halt eigentlich nur mathematisch vorhanden. Real sind die unterschiedliche Wellenlängenbereiche. Und mit unserer Kamera, mit der Telekamera, können wir quasi wirklich drei echte Farbbilder machen, die dann auch wirklich die volle 2000 x 2000 Auflösung haben. Das heißt, vom Prinzip her, wenn wir das Panorama machen, dann dreht sich der Kamerakopf ein bisschen, macht die drei Farbfotos, bewegt sich ein Stück, macht die drei Farbfotos, bewegt sich ein Stück, macht die drei Farbfotos und dann werden diese drei Farbfotos übereinander gelegt, damit man dann die Farbe hat und dann zusammengestitcht. Und da kommt dann ein Gigapixel-Panorama raus.
Was ändert sich an der Kamera, damit er die unterschiedlichen Farben macht? Ist das so ein beweglicher Filter oder was?
Das ist so ein Filterrad. Genau, das fährt dann einfach da durch. Also theoretisch könnten wir sogar noch verschiedene, können wir noch andere Spektralbereiche, das Panorama machen oder wir könnten verschiedene Fokusebenen machen, dass die Daten multiplizieren sich dann halt sehr schnell.
Okay, aber mit der Kamera kriegt man auf jeden Fall eine extreme Schärfe hin, weil man eben nicht diese Verschmierung schon auf der niedrigsten Ebene hat, das ist sozusagen rein softwaretechnisch so die reine Leere. Da kommt halt einfach der Pixel, so wie er ist und durch den Filter nimmt man eben sozusagen den Farbeffekt raus, aber so richtig farbig ist es da ja nicht auf dem Mond, was die Kameras bisher so rausgegeben haben.
Das ist eine, wir haben uns tatsächlich über eine relativ lange Zeit gefragt, ob wir eigentlich überhaupt Farbkameras oder Farbbilder liefern wollen. Das ist noch nicht ganz entschieden. Also es kann sein, dass wir tatsächlich für bestimmte Strecken, die langweilig sind, einfach nur Schwarz-Weiß-Bilder übertragen werden, merkt man ja eh nicht.
Haben denn die Astronauten gesagt, dass sie dann einen anderen Eindruck von der Umgebung hatten, als das jetzt auf dem Foto- und Filmpaterial rüber kam? Ich meine, die Qualität der Filme war natürlich ohnehin schlecht, aber was so die Farben betrifft, konnten die von irgendwelchen Farben berichten?
Nein, also außer dieses Orange Soil, das ist halt so ein Fleck, auch bei Apollo 17, wo wir nochmal gerne hinfahren würden, wenn wir denn dann Zeit dafür haben, haben die eigentlich nicht darüber berichtet, dass es irgendwelche Farbe irgendwo groß gegeben hat.
Orange Soil, also es gab schon was Fleckiges sozusagen auf dem Boden.
Genau, also das war halt irgendwie so ein einfachen Orangen Fleck, den sie da gefunden haben, wo sie nicht genau wissen, wo der eigentlich herkommt und was der...
Na gut, ich meine, allein dafür lohnt es sich ja zumindest mal, das entsprechende Equipment an Bord zu haben. Und wer weiß, ich meine, wenn man jetzt mit aktueller Kameratechnik, 40 Jahre, 45 Jahre nachdem der Sport stattgefunden hat, nochmal draufschaut, aber das dürften ja die Chinesen dann eigentlich auch gemacht haben vor zwei Jahren.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, das waren Farbaufnahmen. Also, die Bilder sind halt alle grau. Aber die haben auf jeden Fall aktuelle Fotos mal gemacht, ja.
Okay, also von Farben, also von Farbenpracht weiß man bisher sozusagen nicht viel.
Ja, also es gibt halt so manchmal so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen, es gibt halt das Grau, was man kennt, und es gibt dann manchmal so ein bisschen, so einen leichten Gelbstich und es gibt einen leichten Blaustich manchmal. Das sind so die beiden Farben, in Anführungszeichen, die man so kennt. Aber viel Farbe ist da definitiv nicht, ne?
Na gut, naja, das ist auf jeden Fall mal ganz sinnvoll, das ordentlich aufzubereiten. Also, das Live-Übertragen ist ja das eine. Da muss man dann, also für ein Live-Bild, wo man jetzt eine Rover-Steuerung macht, da muss man ja komprimieren. Da nimmt man quasi nur so ein Minimum. Aber die eigentlichen Aufnahmen, wenn man jetzt mal so ein Gigapixel-Panorama macht, dann will man ja im Idealfall überhaupt nichts komprimieren. Also abgesehen jetzt von Datenkompressionen, die halt verlustfrei sind. Das dauert aber dann wahrscheinlich doch ziemlich lange, das zu übertragen.
Ja, aber man kann ja, also wie gesagt, es gibt ja auch zum Beispiel die JPEG 2000, gibt es ja auch eine verlustfreie Komprämierung, die tatsächlich noch einiges rausholen, um die Datenmenge zu reduzieren. Aber ja, es kann sein, dass wir teilweise einfach rumstehen, um noch Daten wieder zur Erde zu übertragen.
Wenn jetzt eins der Antennenmodule, wenn die Kommunikation mit einem der Rover nicht gelingt, gibt es da noch so ein Fallback, dass man über den anderen Rover oder über Alina, über den Lender noch mit denen sprechen kann? Haben die nochmal so Bluetooth? Also gibt es noch eine Möglichkeit, lokal noch mal Funk vorzunehmen?
Da frag mich am besten in einem halben Jahr noch mal dazu. Dann kann ich da was dazu sagen.
Das finde ich erstaunlich. Du hast das jetzt schon ein paar Mal gesagt, dass so ja, wissen wir noch nicht so genau, mal gucken und so. Man würde ja nun erwarten, also wann rechnest du mit dem Launch, wenn alles gut läuft?
Also unser Startdatum, unser frühest Startdatum, ist Ende 2017. Wir werden aber davon ausgehen, dass es sich an Anfang 2018 orientiert.
So, aber in Raumfahrt-Missionsdimensionen ist das ja quasi morgen.
So.
Und dann sozusagen, wir schlafen jetzt noch mal drüber morgen früh, kurz vor dem Start. Schauen wir mal, was wir hier so software-technisch noch oder hardware-technisch noch realisieren können. Das ist ein bisschen ungewöhnlich, also ich bin es jetzt gewohnt von Missionsschilderungen, dass eigentlich der Umfang einer solchen Mission sehr früh extrem genau festgelegt wird. Ihr seid da irgendwie ein bisschen flexibler. Was gibt euch da die Sicherheit oder ist das jetzt einfach nur so der Wahnsinn, der die fette Beute hier schon gemacht hat?
Ja, also es ist natürlich ein bisschen Wahnsinn dabei, aber es ist halt auch einfach sehr viel, dass wir einfach modernere Entwicklungsmethoden benutzen. Also in der Raumfahrt wird halt gerne so ein V-Modell benutzt, wo man dann halt einfach erstmal anfängt, eine Riesenspezifikation zu machen. Und wir arbeiten halt wesentlich agiler. Wir wissen, dass einige der Features, die wir uns vorstellen, dass die dann im Ende vielleicht nicht drin sein werden. Aber wir haben das Bear-Minimum quasi auch jetzt schon quasi fertig. Also das, was wir, wir könnten, wenn wir jetzt den Rover hochschicken würden, dann wären wir schon in der Lage, damit herumzufahren, die Bilder zu übertragen. Aber wir würden halt nicht unsere volle Performance bringen können. Wir würden nicht mit 3,6 kmh herumfahren können. Die Datenraten wären, die Bildraten wären niedriger, als es sein müsste. Also wir haben quasi, wir haben quasi ein Baseline geschaffen und auf dieses Baseline setzen wir jetzt immer weiter auf und versuchen, immer mehr rauszuholen.
Das heißt, ihr seid auch in hohem Maße in der Lage, dann vor Ort unter Umständen auch noch mal zu reagieren und zu sagen, so hier gibt es sich eine Gelegenheit, die wir so bisher noch nicht auf dem Zeiger hatten. Jetzt spielen wir nochmal neue Software ein und gucken wir mal, ob wir hier nicht irgendwie ein interessantes Tänzchen machen können, mit der Kamera andere Manöver fahren, als wir das uns bisher gedacht haben.
Genau. Also wobei es ist zum Beispiel eine Möglichkeit, dass man tatsächlich noch eine Teilautonomie mal ausprobiert. Das würden wir dann aber in einem Bereich machen, der von Apollo-17 weiter weg ist. Das ist sowas für Tag zwei oder für den nächsten Mondtag.
Ja, also wenn man überlebt sozusagen.
Ein bisschen Technologie testen.
Aber die Hardware muss ja doch relativ bald festgelegt werden, oder? Weil es ja dann auch Anforderungen, würde ich mal sagen. Wer testet denn das alles?
Das machen wir effektiv. Also die Hardware steht schon zu, ich sag mal, 90 Prozent. Und da baut man sich dann halt Hardware in den Loop-Simulatoren auf, mit denen man dann die testen kann.
Also ich meine, bei ESA Mission ist es ja so, wenn das Ding fertig gebaut ist und wenn es so irgendwie die Rakete soll, dann geht das erst erstmal nach Holland, ins Estec, ins Testcenter und dann wird das dann irgendwie im Vakuumkammer gestellt und Rüttelmotoren und Pipapo und wird bestrahlt und was nicht alles. Und erst wenn diese ganzen Tests durch sind, wird überhaupt erst das Go gegeben, das darf jetzt hier auch in unsere Rakete rein. Wenn man jetzt zu so einem Anbieter, was auch immer es jetzt werden sollte, SpaceX oder diese Launcherlines, welche Anforderungen haben die denn? Testen die dann auch noch mal unabhängig oder sagen die einfach nur, hier ist unser Formular, das müsst ihr mal alles durchgeschaut haben und passt schon irgendwie? Weil so eine Payload, die ihr Eigenleben entwickelt oder die vielleicht nicht richtig austariert ist und so weiter, kann ja auch diese Rakete quasi in Gefahr bringen. Also die werden ja dann sicherlich auch gewisse Anforderungen stellen.
Genau, die finalen Tests nach der Integration sozusagen, die führen wir natürlich noch genauso aus. Also da geht es dann auch wirklich um diese Thermal-Vacuum- und Vibrationstests. Wir haben aber halt auch verschiedene Tests schon gemacht für die einzelnen Komponenten, natürlich, und was dann fehlt, ist halt, das Gesamte quasi nochmal zu testen. Das ist dann das, was man dann halt dann kurz vor dem Start nochmal macht.
Aber er macht ja sozusagen einfach nur so nach eigenen Regeln. Es gibt jetzt kein Regelwerk der internationalen Raumfahrt, was man jetzt befolgt.
Also wir müssen halt dem Lounge-Provider darlegen können, dass wir sicher sind, dass das, was wir gebaut haben, seine Rakete nicht gefährdet. Und in welcher Form das im Detail dann ist, wird dann halt ausgehandelt. Also wenn wir jetzt dann einfach sagen, es gibt so eine Verified-by-Engineering-Istheorie, das wird schon so passen, das kann manchmal funktionieren, aber manchmal ist das halt nicht genug. Und dann muss man halt mit einer Testkampagne das nochmal nachziehen. Es kann sein, dass der sagt, okay, also die Tests, die ihr dort gemacht habt, die entsprechen nicht dem Stand der Technik oder die waren uns aber durchgeführt, oder da habt ihr das nicht bedacht, macht ihr nochmal. Das kann schon passieren. Aber das wird halt gemeinsam erarbeitet. Also wir müssen jetzt zum Beispiel schon einen Massen-Dummy abliefern. Also nicht den physikalischen, sondern das modellmäßige, damit der schon mal gucken kann, ob das von der Masse her, nach der Integration in der Rakete, so funktioniert mit den Schwingungen. Also da muss man auch noch ein Resonanzmodell dann nachliefern. Und das sind die Schritte, die man halt schon während den Startvorbereitungen liefern muss.
Also Massen-Dummy ist quasi kein funktionales Ding, aber was quasi in seiner Masseverteilung, in seiner inneren Struktur, dem entspricht, was man letzten Endes an Bord geben möchte. Wie ist denn das mit so Weltraumschreut-Anforderungen? Also wenn ihr jetzt irgendwie da in der Nacht noch rumsteht und darauf hofft, am nächsten Montag noch mal aufzuwachen vielleicht, dann würde das ja im Prinzip auch bedeuten, dass man sich nicht komplett abschaltet.
Na ja, in der Nacht sind wir komplett abgeschaltet, weil da läuft jetzt jemand die Batterie aus.
Ja gut, aber ich weiß noch bei Rosetta jetzt, die ja zum Schluss der Mission dann auf den Kometen runtergelassen wurde und dort quasi gecrasht ist, wurde ja Rosetta kurz vor Auftreffen der Oberfläche auch irreversibel abgeschaltet.
Genau.
Um einfach sicherzustellen. Weil viele, weiß ich es ehrlich gesagt nicht, ist ja im Prinzip in so einem Modus mit, wenn ich genug Strom habe, dann wache ich mal wieder auf. Man weiß ja jetzt auch nicht, wie viele das überleben wird. Könnte aber in 70 Jahren ja im Prinzip nochmal aufwachen. Das heißt, an der Stelle ist man dann schon auch konform mit den Regularien. Weil es gibt ja diese Anforderungen, dass man eben am besten nichts hinterlässt, was spätere Missionen gefährden könnte. Und wenn da jetzt irgendwas ist, was crazy rumfunkt, immer wenn Sonne drauf strahlt, ohne dass man das in irgendeiner Form unter Kontrolle hat, würde das ja dann auch zukünftige Missionen, sagen wir mal, man möchte dann auch nochmal da landen, kriegt aber dann irgendwie kein freies Band, weil die ganze Zeit diese Eurover da rumschreit.
Richtig, genau.
Dann wäre das ja ein Problem. Also muss man da irgendwas tun?
Also man muss natürlich, es ist natürlich klar, dass also nach dem Aufwachen ist der Rover dann halt erst mal in einem Listen-Only-Mode. Das heißt, er hört wirklich einfach nur, ob es dann, ob da ein neues Kommando reinkommt. Und nur wenn er ein Kommando detektiert hat, was ihn, was ihn halt dann effektiv einschaltet, dann werden halt die Systeme eingeschaltet überhaupt. Also gerade das X-Band, das wird dann überhaupt erst bei Bedarf eingeschaltet.
Okay, also er macht im Prinzip nur so Design-Command-Kontroll-Kanal auf, lauscht, so, wollt ihr mich noch haben? Und dann schickt man da so einen Ping hin und dann so, ah, okay, alles klar, ihr könnt mich noch gebrauchen, dann leg ich jetzt mal los. Gut, es kann ja keiner garantiert dafür geben, dass irgendwas so schief geht, dass er dann trotzdem die ganze Zeit rumschreit, wenn halt die Software nicht ordentlich war. Aber man ist schon ver- also ist das nur so eine moralische Verpflichtung oder müsst ihr euch dann auch quasi als Teilnehmer der Raumfahrt auch konkret verpflichten, um überhaupt erst einen Launch zu bekommen? Also gibt's da so Regularien?
Ah, das ist, das ist alles ganz schwierig.
Weltraumrecht und so.
Ja, also das ist, also was wir müssen und was wir tun, sind halt, sind halt zwei relativ verschiedene Paar Schuhe. Es gibt, es gibt halt viele Dinge, die wir, die wir tun, weil so natürlich, also zum Beispiel Planetary Protection Act, dass man halt sagt, okay, wir bauen unser, der Mond ist zum Glück die niedrigste Klasse, wir bauen unser Mond, unsere Hardware halt in einem, in einem Rheinraum zusammen oder sowas. Da halten wir uns halt einfach dran. Ob wir da jetzt rechtlich dazu verpflichtet sind, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht.
Also Rheinraum, damit man jetzt zum Beispiel keine Bakterien oder anderen Stoffe der Erde quasi, die jetzt nicht unmittelbar zum Gerät gehören, mitführt und dort kontaminiert. Und dann kommt die nächste Mission und sagt, oh, wir haben hier, was weiß ich, Gold gefunden und so. Und dann ist das Gold aber nur von der Mission vorher da schon hingebracht.
Genau, darum geht es vom Prinzip. Das ist beim Mond halt ziemlich unkritisch. Also wenn wir jetzt eine Mars-Mission machen, dann wären die Anforderungen deutlich anders. Also beim Mond, da weiß man, da gedeiht eh nichts. Ob da jetzt eine Mikrobe mitfliegt oder nicht, ist jetzt auch nicht so wichtig. Also da muss man keine Sterilisationsprozesse zum Beispiel durchführen. Beim Mond reicht es, wenn man dann das in einem Klasse-8-Reihenraum zusammenbaut.
Ja, Carsten, wenn das jetzt alles geklappt hat, ich meine, es ist ein bisschen schwierig, da jetzt drüber zu reden, weil das ist irgendwie das große Fragezeichen. Aber sagen wir mal so, eine gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeit ist da. Leute setzen sich damit auseinander, Geld wird investiert. Dinge sind auch schon gebaut worden. Und am Ende, wenn man es vor 45 Jahren mit großem Aufwand schon mal geschafft hat, dann natürlich heute unsere Voraussetzungen mit all dem Wissen, was wir haben, mit all der extrem abgehangenen Kommunikationstechnik und auch nicht mit zu revolutionären Ansätzen. Ich meine auch dieses Rover-Prinzip, die Art und Weise, wie die Dinge im Prinzip strukturell gebaut sind, das ist jetzt schon seit vielen, vielen Jahren auf dem Mars sehr erfolgreich. Also trotz des kompletten neuen organisatorischen Rahms, die ihr euch gegeben habt, bewegt ihr euch ja noch in relativ entspannten Anforderungsbereichen. Ich will das jetzt nicht klein machen. Ich sage nur, ihr versucht ja jetzt auch nicht alles, jedes Rad komplett neu zu erfinden. Es geht überhaupt erstmal um die Leistung des Vor allem möglichst günstig zu machen, effizient zu machen, auch im Softwarebereich sehr agil zu machen und dadurch sozusagen auch neue Möglichkeiten zu schaffen, weil wenn man beweisen kann, okay, wir machen das Ganze jetzt aber mal, ohne dass eine führende Weltwirtschaft 20 Prozent seines Bruttosozialprodukts dafür ausgeben muss, für fünf Jahre, um das irgendwie zu erreichen, dann ist das ja auch schon mal eine Ansage. Was könnte denn aber dann trotzdem, so in the long run, aus diesem Ansatz heraus entstehen? Also was sind die Türen, die quasi euer Projekt hier öffnen könnte, außer noch andere zu motivieren, Ähnliches zu tun?
Naja, also unsere Motivation quasi als Firma ist es halt wirklich, das Space Exploration quasi günstig zu machen, also dass mehr Teilnehmer schaffen, einen Nutzlast zum Beispiel zum Mond zu bringen, um dann, also das ist dann zum Beispiel eine kleine Universität, die jetzt ein Instrument entwickelt hat, dass dies dann schafft, dieses auch mal tatsächlich zum Mond zu bringen. Und vom Prinzip her wollen wir quasi den Grundstein für das Moon Village legen, dass das auch wirklich dann mal vorankommt. Da gibt es ja auch eine Menge, was getan werden muss. Also da müssen dann Precursor-Missionen gemacht werden, wo man sich verschiedene Stellen mal genau anschaut. Und eine unserer zukünftigen Missionen wird auf jeden Fall an den Südpol gehen, wo wir uns dann wirklich mal ganz anderes Terrain angucken und ganz andere Anforderungen an den Landeprozesse haben und sowas. Und das werden wir halt kontinuierlich weiterentwickeln und auch als Geschäftsmodell weiter betreiben.
Also ihr seid erstmal abonniert auf den Mond auf jeden Fall. Weil da gibt es ja eigentlich noch eine ganze Menge zu holen.
Es gibt aber auch andere Monde, die auch interessant sind. Also Phobos zum Beispiel, die sind vom Delta-V her ziemlich gleich. Also von dem Spritzverbrauch, sag ich jetzt mal.
Achso, um auf Phobos, also der Marsmond, zu landen, braucht man genauso viel Sprit wie beim normalen Mond?
Ziemlich, ja. Aha, warum ist das so? Weil, Orbitalphysik. Also, das ist einfach so. Das zieht ja auch kaum an, also ich könnte mir eher vorstellen, dass das nochmal schwierig ist. Es ist auf jeden Fall irgendwie möglich, dass man dort, zum Beispiel auch mit Alina, in einer weiterentwickelten Variante tatsächlich hinfliegen könnte.
Okay, hat ja so eine ähnliche Gravitation auch für unsere. Das müsste ja noch viel schwächer sein.
Das ist wesentlich schwächer.
Viel kleiner, ne? Okay, gut, das ist auch nochmal eine Perspektive. Aber trotzdem, diese Idee des Monddorfs, das zieht ja eine ganze Menge nach sich. Das heißt, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, ihr seid eigentlich im Prinzip auf dem Weg, jetzt selber Nutzen dieser eines Providers, nämlich eines Launch-Providers zu sein, hin zu selber ein Provider zu sein für alles, was auf dem Mars stattfindet. So nach dem Motto, äh, schon, zum Mond stattfindet. Also nach dem Motto, ihr wollt was auf dem Mond machen, wir bringen euch dahin. So ein Reisebüro für Mond-Experimente, sozusagen. Man kann ja jetzt auch schon was mitschicken. Woran denkt ihr denn, Nils? Jetzt kann man nur so Dinge da ablegen oder sind da noch andere Experimente auch möglich?
Also wir haben halt mit wirklich mit sehr vielen Institutengeräten, die halt Instrumente entwickelt haben, die sie gerne auf die Mond-Oberfläche bringen würden. Aber derzeit halt nicht in der Lage sind, das finanziell zu machen, bzw. das in dem kurzen Zeitraum, den wir haben, auch wirklich fertig zu bekommen. Es gibt halt, ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, es gibt aus dem biologischen Bereich und aus dem geologischen Bereich im Bereich der Insitu Resource Utilization, also man versucht Materialien aufzubereiten, gibt es einige sehr interessante Experimente, z.B. Wasserdetektierung ist auch ein Experiment, was am Südpol sehr interessant wäre.
Also man weiß, dass es da Wasser gibt.
Genau, und die Frage ist dann konkreter, wie zugänglich ist das? Da gibt es dann Missionen, die vorsehen, dass man mit einem Bohrer in den Untergrund reinbohrt und sich dann die Gase anschaut, die dann dabei entstehen. Und dadurch dann eine Bodenzusammensetzung auch in den tieferen Ebenen sich anschaut. Also beim Mond gibt es noch eine Menge Dinge, die wir nicht wissen, die erforscht werden können. Und einige davon sind halt Technologiedemonstrationen, die halt für das Moon Village interessant sind.
Sind wir jetzt schon so weit, so Second Coming of the Moon? Ist das jetzt die Zeit? Beginnt jetzt irgendwie die nächste Mond-Ära?
Ich würde sagen, ja. Also wir sind gerade wirklich an einem Punkt in der Raumfahrt, wo es wieder aufgewacht ist. Und die kommerziellen Anbieter, gerade SpaceX, haben einfach gezeigt, dass das Raumfahrt nicht immer wahnsinnig teuer sein muss. Und durch den neuen Preis gibt es halt auch neue Möglichkeiten. Und durch die Technologie natürlich auch. Durch die neue Technologie, die wir jetzt haben, können wir halt auch noch viel mehr machen. Und ich glaube, dass der Mond halt wirklich als Sprungbrett ins Weltall extrem interessant ist. Es ist quasi so, dass Baby-Blunch-Blacken, um mal ein bisschen sich auszurubieren, und wenn etwas schief läuft, ist man dann drei Tagen immer noch wieder auf der Erde, wenn man möchte. Und da ist es natürlich für einen als Precursor zu einer bemannten Mars-Mission schon extrem interessant. Weil wenn man halt auf halbem Weg zu Mars feststellt, dass man irgendwas vergessen hat, dann tut das halt richtig weh. Beim Mond ist das halt ganz einfach.
Ich freu mich auch, ob man nicht einfach mit dem Mond sehr viel mehr prototypen könnte. Vielleicht ist das alles nicht so vergleichbar, aber sagen wir mal, jetzt die gescheiterte Länder-Mission von ExoMars, die war ja auch so gedacht, als wir testen das jetzt mal. Insofern, das wird ja gerne, wurde es ja den Medien dann so als so ein kleines Scheitern, bis großes Scheitern, je nachdem, wie man das so dargestellt wissen wollte, bezeichnet. Die ESA hat da eine, wie ich finde, recht nachvollziehbare Argumentation, dass sie gesagt hat, das war der Test, der eigentliche Länder kommt in zwei Jahren. Und ja, das hat jetzt vielleicht nicht geklappt, aber immerhin war das jetzt nicht die Hauptmission und genau das war Sinn und Zweck dieser ganzen Sache. Und nur weil es halt jetzt nicht gleich von vornherein funktioniert hat, heißt es ja nicht, dass wir nichts gelernt haben. Wir wissen ja auch, was alles funktioniert hat und das ist ja auch schon mal eine Information. Trotzdem hätte man ja im Prinzip, so wie dieser Fehler jetzt gelagert war, wahrscheinlich das auf dem Mond auch herausfinden können, oder?
Vielleicht, ja. Wobei natürlich beim Mars hat man die Probleme mit Taumeln, die ja glaube ich auch dafür verantwortlich waren, dass dieser Sensor da so überladen wurde. Das sind so Dinge, die man dann auf dem Mond nicht hat. Aber generell, wenn man jetzt eine Kolonie aufbauen möchte, dann muss man sich natürlich fragen, wie baue ich diese Kolonie auf? Nehme ich da einfach irgendwelche Metallröhren, in denen man drin lebt? Oder mache ich da etwas Fortgeschritteneres, dass ich versuche, das Material vor Ort zu benutzen, um das zu drucken? Welche Vor- und Nachteile hat das? Und wie mache ich eigentlich das Schleusenhandling? Das ist ja eine extrem schwierige Frage, auch auf dem Mars. Die Schleuse muss ja über mehrere Jahre gut funktionieren. Und das, obwohl da dieser Staub herumgewirbelt wird auf dem Mars. Und auf dem Mond hat man halt auch dieses Staubproblem zum Beispiel.
Der sich überall rein frisst, weil er so mega dünn ist.
Und wie macht man das mit dem Nachschub, mit der Wassergewindung, mit der Sauerstoffaufbereitung, mit dem Pflanzenwachstum und so weiter? Also da gibt es eine Menge, was man auf dem Mond machen kann, um eine ordentliche Marskolonie vorzubereiten.
Ich finde das insofern eigentlich auch sehr schön mit der privaten Initiative, weil ich höre das bei dir raus und ich spüre das auch selber schon. Man merkt eigentlich, da geht noch so viel auf dem Mond, was eigentlich total cool ist. Man kann eine ganze Menge coole Sachen machen, man kann Technik ausprobieren, aber man kann halt auch wirklich eine ganze Menge Erfahrung und Erkenntnisse gewinnen, sicherlich auch in wissenschaftlicher Hinsicht, weil der Mond ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch noch untersucht ist. Nur, dass es halt jetzt eben so lange Zeit keine Mission gegeben hat, obwohl der Mond irgendwie auch so ein bisschen der Kick-Off an sich der ganzen Raumfahrt war. Also klar, Raketen und so weiter wollte man auch schon vorher haben, allein schon des militärischen Nutzens wegen. Aber man hat ja dann mit dem Mond auch gemerkt, dass Raumfahrt auch in der Lage ist, eine Begeisterung und eine Identitätsstiftung auch zu leisten, die so kaum etwas anderes eigentlich heranbringen kann. Trotzdem kam es halt nie zu solchen Missionen mehr, weil eben der wirtschaftliche Nutzen nicht so unmittelbar sichtbar war, nehme ich mal an. Oder auch vielleicht der politische Nutzen und die Melange aus beiden. Aber jetzt scheint ja wieder so ein ganz neues Interesse aufgekommen sein, wo vielleicht den privaten Unternehmen auch einfach mal Use-Cases einfallen, die so in so einem öffentlichen System überhaupt nicht stattfinden.
Ja, also was ich halt besonders interessant sehe, ist, dass die ISS, wie man sie jetzt kennt, die ist ja quasi jetzt fertig und wird jetzt noch ein paar Jahre Forschung liefern. Aber es gibt halt auch schon Pläne, die quasi abzusetzen. 24, 26, 28 ist da so in der Diskussion. Und die Frage ist, was folgt darauf? Macht man nochmal eine neue ISS? Macht ja keinen Sinn irgendwie. Sondern ich finde dann, ich finde halt sowas auf dem Mond halt irgendwie ziemlich sexy. Im Gegensatz halt zum Mars. Also auf Mars fände ich es natürlich noch besser, aber es ist halt noch schwieriger da hinzukommen, sage ich mal.
Vor allem auch wieder wegzukommen.
Das auch, genau.
Also ein Riesenvorteil vom Mond, dass man da auch relativ entspannt wieder wegkommt oder mal jemand mal abholen könnte oder so. Alles vorstellbar. Na gut, ich meine, die ISS erfüllt natürlich noch eine Rolle, die auch ein Mondfilet schon nicht erfüllen kann. Bis man halt einfach Schwerelosigkeitsforschung machen kann. Das ist sicherlich auf dem Mond auch ganz interessant mit so wenig Schwerelosigkeit, aber auch wenig Schwerkraft ist Schwerkraft. Aber man könnte natürlich ganz andere Herausforderungen dort annehmen. Aber ich muss auch dir zustimmen. Also der Gedanke, dass es keine Weltraumstationen gibt. Und wenn man irgendwie howmanypeopleareinspacerightnow.com eingibt, dass da Null steht.
Genau, das finde ich auch sehr unbefriedigend.
Das ist irgendwie keine Lösung, das liegt gar nicht, oder? Tja, Carsten. Ich glaube, jetzt haben wir es ganz gut eingekreist, was ihr da so vor habt. Ich finde das irgendwie total wild und exciting. Ich wünsche euch da auf jeden Fall viel Erfolg noch so und viele gute Ideen. Und dass das irgendwie alles mit dem Start auch klappt und dass die Rakete nicht explodiert, und was dann halt nicht alles noch schiefgehen kann. Das ist ja immens, das wäre natürlich ein großer Verlust. Aber das würde euch am Ende natürlich auch nicht aufhalten, oder?
Nee, also erstmal vielen Dank. Und ich denke, dass wir wirklich alles versuchen werden, um diese Mission durchzuziehen und hoffen, dass das dann nicht nur bei dieser einen Mission bleibt, sondern dass es dann mehr daraus kommt.
Weltraumbefahrung aus Berlin heraus finde ich auch immer ganz gut. Muss man nicht so weit reisen.
Da freue ich mich auch schon drauf, das Mission Control aufzusetzen.
Und vielen Dank wieder mal an alle hier fürs Zuhören bei Raumzeit. Ich wünsche euch noch viel Spaß. An den nächsten Themen wird schon fleißig geplant und gearbeitet.